[Music]
good morning
everyone as chair of the subcommittee on
sp55 I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 in the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically please note that
there's no physical location for members
of the public to observe in w
contemporan to this meeting however in
accordance with the emergency order I am
confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar
through the electronic calendar on the
General Court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
271-3600 or email
HCS
l.st do. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled please
note that all votes are taken during the
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking Moll
call attendance when each member states
their present please also State whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know
law representative leus I'm pres in the
gr I am present in my home office alone
representative
Schultz good morning I am present in
conquered in my home and my husband will
be in and out of the
room representative
lar hi good morning um in Nash at home
and some family here and there very good
thank
you okay let's begin
hb5
ex5 Phil establishes the position of
temporary health partner authorizes
emergency licensing of medical providers
authorizes covid-19 testing vaccination
by pharmac assistant pharmacy
technicians permits out ofate pharmacies
provide investigational drugs to
clinical trial participants in New
Hampshire to be temporarily licensed as
mail order of pharmacies and protects
the pre-existing non-informed use status
of Summer Camps that were unable to
operate during the summer of 2020 due to
covid-19 and establishes procedures to
allow construction to continue during
the pandemic and temporarily allows
expanded outdoor
dining
there also a Amendment for us today that
we'll be discussing as well we'll get to
that course anyone have any thoughts
let's see where we stand on
this um representative Le temporary
health partner one um I'm okay with that
it's we actually discussed this some as
part of uh think there was an item in
133 that was related to this but
um
it it just seems it's it's a i it was
permitted under the state of emergency
and I think the idea is to let people
get a foot in the door with minimal
training and get further training both
on the job and then they're still going
to be required to uh to do the
continuing
education and you know and then they can
proceed if they want to actually become
lnas in which case they'll have to meet
all the LNA requirements but at least
Tes heard is that it will get them in
the door see they could decide if that's
something they wanted to do and will
also provide U so much need of
assistance for nurses and L which we
have an incredible shortage of right
Gera thank you Mr
chair state of emergencies are enacted
be I mean executive orders during state
of emergencies are enacted because of
certain situation in this case it was
the need for healthcare workers due to
the covid pandemic and the increase in
hospitalizations um for those PE for
people who had contracted that virus I
don't believe that things like this that
are um put under um executive order in
in an emergency are warranted to
continue I don't uh support excuse me
reducing the requirements for this
position based permanently based
on the uh the the current
situation um I believe that people who
are lnas are should have the
qualifications to start um
and I don't support
155 um representa pearon thank you Mr
chairman um the committee of which I'm
the chairman which is Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs um
committee is comprised mostly of doctors
and psychologists and therapists and
medical administrators and so on uh no
surprise there and we've looked at the
idea of various power
P Personnel not just in emergencies but
going forward we're trying to figure out
what we can do to to help the undeserved
areas not just the Northland but other
places as well and while we are very uh
convinced that people need to be trained
and supervised all up and down the
various you know ladders of professional
jobs we also see there is a place not
just in an emergency but at other times
for such um well we're calling them
emergency workers now but going forward
they might not be but people who can
come in be specifically trained to a
task or two be supervised and as a
previous speaker said decide whether
this is for them or not so uh just
coming as an outsider from another
committee uh this is the kind of thing
that we've looked upon with some
you thank you Mr chairman appreciate the
opportunity to sitting on the committee
uh sub committee this morning I'd like
to supplement a little bit of what both
my predecessors have said this morning
uh lnas perform vital functions but not
iuns but because asally in nursing homes
uh the care of people who are uh who are
frail and possibly unable to uh to to
take care of things like toileting
themselves and feeding themselves so
forth in a reliable fashion um to the
degree that the lnas are not there to do
this vital uh crucial work uh it's going
to have to be done by somebody else uh
and if that person is a an RN uh who
would likely be the next person uh in
line then that takes them away from
medical functions which which they can
perform but lnas cannnot uh so in
addition to what representative Lea said
it's not merely a question of getting
these people in the door many of them
are already in the door uh Statewide
anyway uh performing these functions um
and and as I say these are crucial vital
functions that have to be done uh in
order for the for the uh the patients at
nursing homes to be adequately cared for
care is the the underlying word here um
and
the uh medical care but U physical care
that they need so I'm very much in
support of uh this then I certainly will
vote for it in the committee when it
comes
time Mr Cher muff are you calling me I
was call Representative Schultz I she
had hand we couldn't hear you sorry yeah
sorry mumbled a little bit yeah we're
having a hard time hearing you this
morning Mr chair for whatever reason um
I just have a few questions
um I saw my mother-in-law become an LNA
and the
training that she went through was kind
of interesting it was sponsored by the
Red Cross it you know the sort of
training that elen go through typically
isn't while it can be through
traditional um you know like community
colleges and
whatnot it isn't that at least what she
went through the traditional type of um
higher
education that I had assumed it would be
which I found interesting I'm curious to
know then with this
designation of someone who's in
training what is the pay
differential and is there any sort of uh
tuition or fee
for let's see if we have anyone who can
answer that question if anyone is in the
jumping and I'll just then if no one can
answer the question you know one of the
things that I did like about the
training that she went through is you
know as an incentive to get folks into
those training classes there was a
guarantee that any tuition being paid
would be um that debt would be cleared
once someone had served in a certain job
by six months or whatever I actually um
thought that whole scheme was kind of
ridiculous so I'm very open to this uh
change if especially since there's such
a desperate need for the um for folks to
perform these jobs and I can't see why
um so long as the important parts of the
training curriculum are met and included
in some way shape or fashion this might
actually be better for the folks going
into this field they wouldn't have to
incur any debt at the um outet but I am
also still concerned then to know if
there is any traditional pay um or if
it's some sort of a training rate I'm
concerned about pay and
tuition um this might be a great way to
get around student loan debt for this
type of position and I like that but um
having the answer to that would be very
important and if there's a pay uh a
graded scale of pay for people who are
in training versus lnas themselves if
someone can answer
that thank you I don't see anything in
the statute prer pay level so I guess
that would be up to the employer we'll
keep an eye out for anyone who they can
answer
[Music]
that
yeah as I recall question that I we were
hearing Rel
133 and
especially for the nursing homes and it
is I'm sorry Mr chair I'm and I
representative like I'm so sorry to
interrupt you I'm just having a horrible
time hearing you there in the committee
room the sound is different than it
normally is and we want to hear you is
this any
better no it's it sounds
muffled I've got a microphone here I
but maybe we need someone
from the staff to help I don't know if
it's that that's what they do but it's
definitely not as good as it normally is
I can contact it to um see if he can
help out at all yeah if you don't mind I
appreciate that is this any better I'm
trying a different
microphone
thought okay in the meantime while we're
trying to get our technical difficulty
without
much I I believe you just called on me
Mr
chair um now you're
muffled yes he did it was you
representative shuy called on thank you
um
I'm not sure this may be a question for
um representative Pearson since he is
here from Health and Human
Services um since we know that even lnas
are technically paid less than what one
would hope to do the work that they do
and these temporary health workers I
understand are paid even less than lnas
are uh this committee did not hear any
great outpouring from folks doing this
kind of work with interest into this
program I was wondering if Health and
Human Services heard from many folks who
would be interested in taking advantage
of
this uh thank you representative Shu and
on the sliding down pay scale
legislators are paid even
less um uh we heard from a few we didn't
hear from a lot uh we heard from other
legislators who have been contacted by
people who are interested my County job
is to be one who looks over our County
nursing home and from that direct
supervision I can tell you we could use
a lot of people at various levels and
because we cannot get the kind of people
that we might normally want in a
particular slot we found this idea
to be very helpful and very creative but
more directly to your one of your
questions uh we really didn't discuss
specifically pay um I know in the
medical facility that I am CEO of is one
of my day jobs uh we bring in people on
a training wage and if they look pretty
good we uh give them a regular job and
bump up their pay accordingly and make
up for some of the shortfall during
their training period I think this would
probably be up to the facility in
question thank you I'm being chair of my
County delegation I'm aware of what
happened at our Marram County Nursing
house but again like I said I know this
being lesser pay and the incentive pay
from a public nursing home is not as
easily made up perhaps as at a private
answer a single p in months I
you thank you Mr chair and I uh too I
don't think would support this section
of uh the bill um you look at what we've
has created a position for the pandemic
a temporary health
partner and this was to address Staffing
shortages at long-term facilities to
meet the
needs um read on further it goes on to
say it's a temporary position um and
temporary is not defined here are these
going to be temporary full-time
positions or truly temporary positions
um well I understand the need for lnas
um
and understand the issues they're having
and bringing in lnas I think the problem
uh with that
is pay not that there's not enough
qualified candidates out there I think I
think we're looking at uh the pay
structure going forward and to bring in
a temporary health partner at a lower
scale than an LNA I don't think is going
to work um scope will work a temporary
health partner thp is a temporary
position this is directly from the bill
limited to assist lnas no definition of
temporary and that's what I have an
issue
with this is supposed to be temporary to
address a an emergency situation which
we're in um this I don't think was meant
to be
longterm um and the only question other
question I have and I don't remember if
this was brought forward in the public
hearing or not um for the County nursing
homes or any of the nursing homes out
there is this reimbursable through um
Medicare
Medicaid because if not it's going to be
an added expense to these
facilities think that was touched on at
that um yeah 133 we got
the as well for these and um as I recall
they said it was reimbursed by Medicare
Medicaid and that actually
limited um you know how much could be
paid other
question question for representative
Pearson and that is um do we have any
idea how many of these uh people Health
Partners actually were
employed during the pandemic was not
bring up it I don't I mean maybe there
was a surge in you during the pandemic
but my understanding is it's been a
serious problem for quite a while and
it's not going to end with the pandemic
so I'm Wonder watch this the uh people
question sorry you're I'm sorry Mr chair
you're um audio is going in and out
me asked
[Music]
question just so you know I have
contacted it and and um I'm not sure
exactly where he is in the building but
Ryan um dorington is on the way so he's
problem
okay to expanded definitely
have
education yes did you did you call my
name probably need to
oh it's really not
microphone is there a I'm
sorry there was a game adustment on the
microphone and
represent looking at it doing little do
some
self-help okay for what it's worth since
I mostly understood what you just said
um it does sound like uh from our
if the output of your microphone is too
high like it's it's too reverberating
from noise on our side that does muffle
what you say so if you have the ability
to control the volume of the output of
your mic if that makes sense to what we
hear if you I think if you lower it a
little bit it that's what the Distortion
sounds like like it's too
how about for me on this mic that I'm on
better so representative peon can hear
me question if you didn't hear it was uh
first of all you know is this an ongoing
issue that's not specific the
pandemic second is how many of these
temporary health par were hired uh
during the uh while the emergency order
is I I think I heard my name if that's
true I'll continue if not just somebody
waved me off your name
sorry
um we have a need for such people in my
opinion both during an emergency and
ongoing because prior to the pandemic uh
Rockingham County nursing home was still
at wit's end needing people at all
levels but a temporary level below our
normal low level was considered a a good
thing to have again people may decide
they like it and then go back and get a
certificate or even a degree uh or they
may decide they don't like it and and
seek employment elsewhere but it is like
a temp job in in you know in high school
uh uh it is temp but um for some people
that turned into something regular um I
I see the need straight across the board
when the pandemic lifts and when it
doesn't of course we have the question
of the bill before us which addresses
temporary I can follow yes so um I the
question was raised and I have it as
well um what makes this temporary I mean
it and does that should that term
actually be in the bill
um I you know we might hope that such
people would move up to
LNA but is that actually a requirements
and if so what's the definition of
temporary in this context well I'm doing
something I told my committee to do and
that's read the bill it's very
informative um I don't see a definition
I would want one
yeah um I can interrupt I just want to
test does this microphone sound better
and is this one working
okay yes thank you think we're back in
business yeah I I did read the bill and
I didn't see it so I just thought you
might have a better idea of the
intent if I if I may I agree with
representative leus I have a concern
about creating a class of employee
that's goal is to become an LNA but
there's no clear definition of when that
should happen so what would prevent um
creating this subclass that was there
forever without actually being able to
make
LNA Mr um shair if I could yes go ahead
representative so this is addressing my
concern which was I don't see any we've
we've had earlier bills where people who
worked in a certain position that didn't
have the training were allowed to
continue that because they had either
worked during the um the pandemic to
account for their training or they had
worked enough hours that they could be
promoted to that position they could get
license share for that I don't see that
here I see that this is a tempor we're
creating class of people who are going
to receive lower pay and have lower
requirements and I don't that's my
concern with this bill if these people
had access to the LNA position or it was
a road to that um that's a whole
different thing so I think that's the
Crux of my concern with the bill and I
appreciate um everyone helping me get to
that Pearson yes thank you Mr chairman
um my Aunt Janet was in the test class
for nurse practitioners in Massachusetts
40 years ago and they were called uh a
variety of names not good enough to be a
doctor uh a subass I remember that but
what my aunt
demonstrated and the two nurse
practitioners that are on under my
employee demonstrate is probably at age
22 they weren't ready to go to medical
school so they did come in eventually as
a subass called nurse practitioner uh
and some of the nurse practitioners now
have gone back and uh become do or MDS
and that's a good thing many of them
stay where they are so subclass or lower
level uh I did I heard the snear behind
the use of that term 40 years ago but I
didn't see it as such I just saw it as
somebody who could move from where she
was to a better position and eventually
uh some of them went on to be better yet
and better yet and better yet and I
could see temporary and I reiterate I
want a definition here a temporary AR
person coming in at a lower level is not
necessarily a bad thing I don't think
it's demeaning to people I think it may
be the lower rung on the ladder that
they can best uh put their foot on at
this time and maybe come up higher and
then higher
yet I am I tend to agree I don't have an
issue with uh with having a a separate
class that's a that's only there as a
stepping
stone but a temporary seems to be the
sticking point here
if when does that become no longer
Shu thank you Mr chair um perhaps
representative Pearson can answer this
thought that occurred to me um we know
that uh health care workers were granted
uh bonus pay if you would call it that
during the pandemic were these folks
that um I don't know we would know that
that would be that would be dependent on
an employer that's not
a I was thinking perhaps Mr
representative Pearson might know that
from his outside connection I see him
shaking his head no he does oh sorry
Schultz M sorry about that um I do see
still a lot of folks in the attendees
list if any of them have an
understanding of how pay differential is
for these two positions that would be
helpful it sounds like there are already
these sort of programs predominantly
because of the pandemic but my you know
I would say if this gives folks a chance
to earn a paycheck and avoid the student
loan debt from the LNA program training
programs um this actually might be net
gain for them I think though LNA pay in
general and uh is it definitely in the
category of workers that definitely
needs a boost and maybe and I agree with
everything that representative goalie
says about that but if the differential
in uh avoiding student loan debt for the
training
programs uh and they earn a paycheck at
the same time might be a better bargain
for that period I believe but it would
be nice to hear some confirmation of
that from anyone in the field um I see
someone from Dartmouth Hitchcock is in
the attendees list and other folks that
we know very well it would be great if
we could if I don't get the answer to
the question during the subcommittee I'm
definitely going to call around and get
the
answer um from various sources I have if
anybody has any recommendations for that
because I think that's to me the biggest
sticking point if they're getting the
same
curriculum uh they would get through the
official training programs and they're
being paid and they're avoiding student
loan debt I think this is a good path
actually but I don't have a confirmation
yet Mr um yes thank you I I think that's
an interesting um to know the pay
differential but I don't know that it's
necessarily
um necessarily important as far as
getting the language of the bill correct
because the pay is going to be different
at every place and it's really going to
be set by the market I'm more concerned
about creating a permanent class of
people who would then be allowed to be
paid less because they don't have the
same credentials that an LNA would have
this should only be a stepping to LNA
not a
permanent class of people that would be
paid lower so it's tangental in in that
in that regard um but it would be
interesting to know um representative
Allegro thank you uh thank you for
taking my question I'm not on this
committee uh but I wanted to be here
this morning because I think this is
important enough that I made the time to
come in early as someone who has done
work push wheelchairs white bottoms and
held hands um I know it's important work
and it doesn't rise at that to the same
level
as what these people will aspire to I
just want to say that we had a shortage
before the pandemic we're going to have
a shortage after the pandemic and I
think we're getting a little far a field
in splitting hairs worrying about
creating an underclass and uh what their
pay is going to be and how temporary is
temporary uh I'll just finish by saying
that there's there's no experience for a
position like this than um firsthand
practical experience and uh much more
important than than classroom training
and credits and that sort of stuff and I
support this uh way to um to ease the
way for people to get into this
profession as much as possible Mr chair
thank you representative Le uh thank you
Mr chair I
actually am not concerned about a lack
of a definition of temporary as it seems
to
be language that isn't NE necessary I
mean I would support amending this to
get rid of call them Health Partners and
get rid of temporary I mean if there if
somebody we're certainly gonna have the
opportunity
mesent
speak understanding was you thought that
could be further
delineated uh yes I
do
okay going on
Sam you need to mute after this meeting
sorry okay thank you um anyway so I'd be
okay just calling them Health Partners
if they're there and getting the
experience they're certainly you they're
making some money and certainly have the
opportunity if they choose to work
towards an LNA I don't think it needs to
be spelled out
explicitly um and if somebody is doesn't
want to do that for some reason and they
want to continue for some period of time
you know maybe even a longer period of
time doing the kind of work under the
supervision of an LNA or you know RN or
um you know that the health partners are
allowed to
do I'm I don't object to that although I
would expect most of the people doing
this would uh take the opportunity to
move up and become lnas and you know be
a good opportunity for for them to do it
and at least make some money so I'd be
okay with that my my my only issue with
that theory is that it could clog the
position from people that would want to
earn their LNA if you had someone who
stayed in it said I'm just going to do
this well someone who might want to take
advantage of that to get their LNA
positions
full yeah I I don't know the the chance
of that given there's been this chronic
shortage and
goalie thank you Mr chair and I'm glad
to see the discussion coming around to
the definition of temporary which was
one of my bigger concerns um because
there is no definition and uh I hope we
stay on keeping this as a temporary
health partner and move these folks up
the chain to that shortage of lnas we
have um I guess my I have one question
and I don't know if we can get help from
Pam or anybody out in the audience um is
the term temporary health partner used
in any other state and defined uh as to
what it is and that may help us on that
end if it is being used thank you help
us from Reinventing the
will M Marling are you aware of that if
that if that's that term is used
anywhere
else see sorry I'm I'm uh in another
meet in and out of another meeting um I
do not know off the top of my head but
I'd be happy to search and find out
appreciate it thank
you um
so real quick I think because I don't
want to stay on this section forever uh
do we all seem to agree that um a
definition of temporary would not hurt
and and for some of us actually help um
the
Bell thumbs
up and would everyone probably support
it then if we could get that locked
down yeah okay if go ahead if that's
what the committee chooses to do my
preference actually would be to
eliminate all references to Temporary
but if the committee our subcommittee
doesn't want to do that then uh getting
the definition in I think would be
better than eliminating it the whole
thing well I I don't I think yeah I I I
prefer to have a to I to to get rid of
it all together would mean it was a
permanent subass of of medical without
the necessary impetus for going forward
I think um but I think if we could just
keep it and Define temporary to a
reasonable amount of time um I think
that it would still carry out the
function of the bill yet make everybody
comfortable we're not creating a
position just to be paid less um does
anyone have an ideas on the thoughts on
the time period for
definition I had my hand up for a while
Mr chairman I'm sorry I can't see you on
the screen but you go ahead M represent
Schmid thank you Mr chairman so uh just
let's bring this back into the focus
that this uh this section and this idea
is primarily for the benefit of the
nursing homes not primarily for the
benefit of the people that are going to
be employed uh it is being driven by the
fact that the nursing homes urgently
crucially need people to do these
significant important vital tasks um
even because they're and representative
Lea said it a moment ago they're under
supervision so not being you know put in
as free agents here they're going to be
under supervision but doing fundamental
tasks that don't take a lot of training
they they just take some uh uh some
guidance um so the temporary aspect
clearly in my mind has something to do
with a pandemic we're not done with a
pandemic no matter how much we would
like to be um and uh and as long as
that's the case uh we we we have to also
take care because one of the aspects of
the pandemic is that you can have
somebody who's in a job whatever the
position might be who uh comes in
contact is exposed to the virus and has
to stop working for for a couple of
weeks uh unlike me many other situations
they are
they're kind of get a timeout uh and so
that makes the the pandemic the the
underlying
premise of this whole situation and if
you want to tie it into that fine if
somebody can come up with a language but
the other aspect of this that I wanted
to address is we don't have to legislate
every damn thing folks uh because once
this this statute is uh in place uh then
you're going to have rules written and
they can get into all kinds of details
as long as the statute enables that so
uh I think we are uh this is beating
kind of beating a dead horse in a way
well the committee appreciates your
in I appreciate that Mr
chairman Mr
chair as long as
um was um
hello can you hear me just hold on a
second I wanted to respond to
representative Schmid sorry the um the
pandemic isn't mentioned in the statute
and it permanently creates the the
category of temporary health part
so we have to comp contemplate well
beyond the pandemic in the ramifications
this would have going forward so I I
agree that the pandemic is what the
impetus of all of this is but this
statute doesn't contemplate just the
pandemic it goes forward so I think it
it would behoove us to have at least a
definition of something that we're
permanently putting in statute um I'm
not I'm not fighting the the idea that a
definition would be helpful but what I'm
saying is that the pandemic is to me is
the driving force for this because
because of the fact that the pandemic
constantly threatens uh a workers's
ability to continue at that particular
time if they've been exposed to the
virus now uh now that we have a vaccine
that's T that's showing itself to be
quite efficacious uh we can perhaps um
reduce the number of incidents of people
having to take that time out but the
pandemic I think is the time frame that
we're operating in I think it's but
continue if you can come up with a with
a good definition I don't have I don't
have any opposition to that thank you uh
representative Pearson thank you Mr
chairman uh on the other computer on my
desk I've been doing research as to what
might be called an underclass in medical
providers um I've noticed that during a
very bad emergency that we were under in
this country called World War II we ran
out of our ends and so there became a
temporary group called LPN but they
found that LPN freed RNs to do more what
RNs were trained to do So lpn's
eventually evolved into an honorable uh
level of medical care so even these
temps we're looking at here um I would
not want to see them as underclass I
would want to see them as another the
layer of helpful Personnel uh that we
need and we don't just need when the
pandemic runs its course uh we're going
to need them we need them now we needed
them before in our County nursing homes
and other places so you know lpn's uh
started off the way this group is
starting off it seems from what I'm
reading on the
screen agre I think we all agree that
that the position itself is is worthy of
discussion I just I think we also agree
that it
if we put a definition on on temporary
to get these folks to the LNA level as
reasonably quick as possible um the
better off everyone involved would be um
so with that said does anyone have an
idea or thoughts on u a definition of
temporary for this so that we can move
on Mr ker I do see someone in the
attendees list with their hand up if
that's something you want to recognize
sorry that may or may not be to the Top
If You stated yeah that's the I've also
had my hand up oh well you would go
first representative G sorry thank you
um I think that it would if we had um if
we looked up the requirements for
becoming an L whatever uh hours I have
two I have two uh thoughts number one uh
as long as we make this a stepping stone
to something else this is fine um if we
create this position as as an entry to
the LNA that's fine I was for many
summer jobs in LNA
myself um so um and then the other thing
is I'm concerned about how many of these
elenas
would how many how many Lenas I mean how
many these temporary health workers are
nurse was supervised because as you know
we have a stressful situation with that
group of workers as as well so I would
want to make sure that we limit we have
a certain amount of of uh we have a
limit on that supervision how many you
know and and if we want to do that in
rules or if we want input from The
Nurses Association on that before we
decide that that's fine I recommend that
we would look at the um hours of on the
job training an LNA has and make it
equivalent to that so if they have the
the practicum hours that an l would have
temporary can you look that up yeah I'll
look it up right
now
um I'm looking to see does this have
does this statute have a a Ru
making rule making clause in it that
made um first let me see this person in
the audience um if they're asking to
out Mr hilts has hand yeah that's who I
contribute
hello you're
muted
sir I did not have my hand up you did
not okay actually you did but that's all
right
stand go ahead represent
it suggest it would seem reasonable to
um have the temporary time frame aligned
with the amount of time that uh a normal
process for lure to obtain LNA would be
uh considered
reasonable I believe representative Gro
is that up right now I think
yeah I'm not sure how
I can also tell you that the average
salary in New Hampshire for an LNA is
hour again I'm not sure how you would
Define the time period but uh I'm sure
there's some kind of standard that oplc
could
provide all right we're going to um
we're going to move on we all agree that
we're going to get a definition and
everyone seems to be in favor of once we
can Define this two hours 200 hours two
hours 200
um the completion a
challenge there's a test and um a
fundamental nursing
course
um which
I I do think that this would be a good
um discussion to have with
oplc but I think I think 200 hours is a
good number for temporary well that's
only five
weeks that's what that's what it is yeah
um I don't think that I don't think
that's going to
fulfill what the statute contemplates
but I agree we should talk about this
yeah are you saying that in Li of
training we could extend the working
hours towards the
license well the statute proposed Bill
already contemplates um somebody working
for a certain amount of time in lie of
the necessary other training okay all
right so it would be okay I understand
so maybe 250 hours or
something we'll get
some oplc all right let's move on to the
have any comments to start that
discussion I believe it's regarding
the pharmacist
assistance isn't it on page two starting
at line
11 emergency licensing process oh yeah I
missed that one that's correct emergency
licensing
process um representative Pearson thank
you not surprising not surprisingly um
this was the kind of thing that would
come up in health and human services and
did and uh the only question about it
that uh a couple of members raised was
the idea that no required continuing
education was mandated but we all know
and I'm married to a physician
they can't stop reading stuff so they
read the journals even if there's no
requirement but we found that in an
emergency and that's clearly what this
is people who have let their license
lapse uh but there's no disciplinary
action involved would be helpful in
emergencies so uh this this bill didn't
come to us but uh your chair did send it
to me and said read it over and talk it
over with some of your committee people
and uh we're pretty good with this about
licensing Physicians from our state and
from other states whose licenses have
recently
lapsed thank
you anyone on the
committee I'm okay with
if you want if you wanted to deal with
that if you really wanted it just under
a declared state of emergency it could
say that under a state of
emergency you know declared by the well
the governor there or the legislature
which are the two bodies that can do
it but uh which I think is sort of
implied but it could be clearer I guess
yeah C emergency that mean there's you
know RSA for colon whatever um defines
that represent
pear thank you Mr chairman uh I would
stretch I would want a broader
definition here uh when I was nine years
old uh two of the doctors in my hometown
died and one of them was away on the
Good Ship hope and we dragged doc Hilton
out of retirement he was 91 and sharp as
attack uh we just dragged him out
because we could there wasn't anybody
that said we couldn't at that time the
idea of hopping into a car or more
likely back then hopping on the bus and
going to the next city to find a doctor
was probably not possible or likely so
the idea that in that localized
emergency that lasted until doc uh
Goldman came back from his uh Good Ship
hope and uh we secured another doctor
for the town it was good to have doc
Hilton available on a very localized
emergency basis this bill is written
would allow for things like that if it
said it was a Statewide emergency as
declared by Governor Council legislature
some combination uh it would eliminate
that situation and its solution that we
had back in Massachusetts in the
1950s but if it was an emergency who was
left up to the medical board to determin
with that
oh okay I'm agree with you think that
would fulfill that represent Pearson I
think so yeah nowadays that's what we
would do medical board would be
petitioned by locality saying we have an
emergency and can we invoke this statute
yeah representative
[Music]
goalie thank you Mr chair and I I too um
I agree that I think emergencies should
be defined and I think it should be a
state of emergency or emergency declared
by this legislature um as we all know
one person's uh definition of emergency
is different than another person's
definition of emergency um so I I think
there's a lot of
uh very very leeway and just leaving it
as an emergency I think uh the first um
reference to making a declared state of
emergency is uh more suffice thank you
representative goie what are your
thoughts on on uh the example that
representative pierer brought up as a
locality has a a shortage of of of
doctors in their locality where the
medical board would be able to declare a
statute I just have concerns like I said
one person's definition of emergency is
different than anothers and I think by
leaving it very broad um May defeat the
purpose of what this part of the statute
was intended for um I think we we know
of a lot of areas in the state
where um the need for Health Care um
individuals have to travel
a distance to get to the healthare they
need um and I I don't think this is the
solution to that
problem well perhaps not but it it it
might it might help um and I'm not
suggesting leaving it AB broad I'm
suggesting actually defining it an
emergency as declared a state emergency
by the governor or a local medical
emergency as defined by the State
Medical Board um in that would be
limited to a shortage of medical
providers in an area and it would be
that um I would have to read into this
just a little bit further I know some of
this talks about uh nursing students and
um giving them temporary lure five month
months prior to um their graduation and
stuff of that nature um we know there
are shortages of nurses is that going to
be
part considered an emergency for a
hospital that they really need nurses
and we're going to be handing out
licenses five months ahead of time um
and that's my
concern when we we all know that they
should be graduating to get their
license um before they go into the
medical
Shu thank you Mr chair um point of
interest on the previous question about
the temporary health workers uh I had
reached out to the head of my County
nursing home while we were discussing it
he was in a meeting but he just got back
to me um he's reasonably sure that those
temporary workers did get the Frontline
stipend uh in pay that was put out he
unfortunately was not able to find
anyone willing to work in that capacity
at our nursing home which I had thought
that was the case but I wanted to verify
it with him that was part of my question
about interest in this particular that
particular category uh and I think as he
stated the lower tear of New Hampshire
probably had a lot of folks interested
but from Marram County North probably
not so much thank you thank you U
representative
Pearson uh thank you Mr chairman uh we
spent a long time in Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
discussing underserved populations in
the state we had considered we are still
considering a bill that would uh license
a graduate of a medical school with an
MD or do in his or her hand but not
matched for a Residency program and some
of us cringed at that because if you
didn't match either you didn't apply to
enough places or people they got your
number and they don't want you and so
we're thinking about either in some
places having no doctor on hand or
having a nurse served like a doctor or
having a retired person who is uh let
his license laps and wants to come back
for a few years and none of this is
terribly happy with this and we're
looking at some alternatives on how do
we populate underserved areas and this
is a big concern and believe me this
isn't going away once this section of
this bill is dealt with it's going to
come back in force in the next few years
um as I say we've discussed this in some
depth and wish we could have fully
completely trained licensed people in
every slot fact is we don't have that so
what is our fallback position that's
what we're really working
through thank you representative G
thank you I empathize with um
representative Pearson and the um indust
and the medical industry and the Service
of New Hampshire however let's be let's
be uh let's look at it from the St the
standpoint of the people that were
serving right we're
underserved um in almost every area
whether it be the medical field or the
daycare industry
or there's many many industries that we
can look at New Hampshire and say we
could do something a little bit better
but we're also in this legis in this in
this group passing legislation that
affects the lives of
people and their health and I would not
want to do anything um the the concept
of well someone is better than no
one is not my idea
of of a pragmatic or safe approach so
let's is take into consideration that
although we have a
need we just
can't
um throw bodies at the problem without
thinking of the responsibility that we
have to the people that are being served
who will trust these
individuals who will trust them like we
trust our medical profession thank
you thank you represent pearon you like
to respond to yes to respond to the
representative believe me in a room full
of Physicians including the former
president of the New Hampshire Medical
Society we would not Advocate throwing
anybody at the problem we would
Advocate throwing or placing someone who
is a level down at the problem at the
people remember doctors care a lot about
people
nurses care a lot about people Medical
Health administrators like me care a lot
about people we wouldn't take anybody in
fact during the pandemic we rejected two
people who applied for jobs here for the
very reason we would take a good quality
person whose training isn't as high as
we all wish it could be until we do some
very serious work at how do we
incentivize such people going to
undeserved areas how much of the their
tuition do we pay how much of their
moving expenses do we pay that's for the
future and we hope not very far in the
future but as of right now as of today
no not anybody at the problem but
certain specially uh vetted people who
don't quite have the qualifications
that's really the conclusion that we are
coming towards in Health and Human
Services
committee thank you um with regard to
this statute I noticed that
um all the licenses issued pursuant to
the statute will expire on before
January 31st of
um so it looks like it's
temporary it's a temporary fix for the
situation representative Gord did you
again no I'm so sorry I didn't put my
hand on apologies that's okay
[Music]
pear does anyone else wish to speak on
this
section
no okay now we will move on to the next
pharmacies
[Music]
on to pharmacist Andes now y anyone like
to speak on
this does everyone seem to be pretty
okay with this the
pharmacy this is section four yeah
section four
page anyone have any issues with
that no okay that's good I made up some
time
next session starts
where 28 page
[Music]
four
state
section that one is dealing that's a
separate thing dealing with them uh the
first section four was dealing with uh
Co tus yeah and section five is
administering covid vaccines section
five
so the covid test was section four and
everybody seemed to be in agreement with
that now let's talk about section five
the Pharmacists and Pharmacy technici
administering covid vaccines does anyone
have anything to say or any issues with
that
section everyone seems to be okay with
that yeah my only comment would be it's
pretty narrow and I'm I'm okay with that
it's just if we end up with a variant
that's no longer called covid-19 then it
won't apply but I think aren't all the
variants just subvariants of Co they may
be I don't know I don't have any
objection to it okay uh representative
pearon you wanted to say something uh
yeah the next one may be called covid
25 and while that is funny uh it's
pretty darn serious because we have no
guarantee we won't get another covid
type in a handful of years um so I'm not
knowing what I'm suggesting here and
rename it uh uh give it its generic
wider term but covid-19 yeah we'll be
done with covid-19 but the next one will
be
coming yeah it does seem that we're
we're getting to this um at the
hopefully what's the tail end of this
and the need for it but to your point it
would be handy to
have regardless of what the right I mean
I'd be okay making it administering any
vaccine unless but maybe there's reasons
not to do that but I don't I don't know
if that would uh that would cross too
many lines go ahead representative
Pearson thank you this comes out of the
uh counterpart Committee in the Senate
to mine in the house and um Senator
Bradley was thinking more directly about
what's right in front of us not taking a
position not even thinking about what
might be Beyond and yeah emergency law
is good but if it's good for this it
might be good for the next one and quite
possibly the word covid-19 could be
replaced with a better term that I don't
have handy in my mind right at the
moment I just think that that would be a
better uh subject for your community to
take up in another bill because um
there's so many different vaccines of
possible side effects that we wouldn't
want just want allow at yeah um so
similar issues with four for testing as
well it says covid-19 covid-19 I I I
would recommend that we just um we leave
these as they are and just pass them and
let them be used so remainer of this
covid-19 issue and if it seems like a
good idea can be brought up in another
bill to you this should have been I
think if some of these were not combined
and were separate bills they could have
gone to uh representative Pearson's
committee and yeah we're floundering
because we don't have a lot of expertise
in this are okay um moving along um
section
six mail order facilities uh out State
pharmacies is temporary uh
representative
Pearson muted oh he doesn't want no
you're waving off um represent LE yeah I
mean this is actually extremely limited
it's it's for them to be able to ship in
uh uh drugs for people that are on
clinical trials um and those aren't I
mean I think this is good in general for
that situation
because you know that way you can get
the drug sent here if it's appropr
let's say you're dealing the trials down
in Boston or even somewhere else no
travel yeah I mean I again I don't have
any particular expertise in this area
but I don't see um any problem with
this anyone else like to speak on the
straightforward this is on the section
on that on the um pharmacist this is the
section on the out ofate um pharmacies
temporarily being able no I'm fine
okay all right then we're all good on
that let's move on to section
seven next section you know what page
it's
[Music]
on oh
yeah this is on the construction workers
I think um no seven I think this is the
summer camp thing where if summer oh
okay they were grandfathered in but they
could lose their grandfather and if they
weren't able to operate um last year or
this you know last summer or this summer
I I certainly support this yeah this
this is a um this is a common sense this
is just fixing what co co wrecked um
anyone else have any comments or
concerns about section 7 with summer
camps no okay um let's move
on Mr chair yes go ahead one quick one
as I'm going through it right now
um I just have one question as to and I
don't see it in here and I don't know if
we can get an answer um does this piece
of the statute does this Sunset so I
mean once this year's over it should be
um I don't think we need to keep this in
place I think we can Sunset it once
we're through the uh amending
it you're you're referring to the summer
camps right there that one is correct
there are some perspective appeals at
ones correct represent I think there are
some repeals in the end that I haven't
got to yet yeah there's uh there are for
the
uh uh emergency licensing procedures we
were discussing a little bit
ago and the the one we just spoke about
the outut ofate pharmacy's temporary
licenses mail
order let's see and also the expansion
of outdoor
dining but I don't
see well this this section of the statue
only pertains to camps that were not
able to operate in
2020 and and fixes the grandfathering
issue whether or not the statute sunsets
it it kind of automattic ically doeses
on its own because it only refers to the
camps that weren't operate be able to
operate in 2020 correct yeah I think the
only reason
for um maybe doing an amendment to have
it go away um after next year is just to
keep the statutes a little
cleaner yeah and I'd be okay with that
okay is that would everyone be okay with
that having this section
sunet can you make a note of that for me
ton y all
right
anything else uh uh representative
goalie you good with that if we Sunset
it I am good with it I just don't think
it needs to be kept on the books uh just
make it confusing we no longer it good
point yeah the statutes are big enough
as it is yeah they are all right um so
now we move on to section
eight construction during a during
covid-19 anyone have any comments or
thoughts in this
[Music]
section I have some comments on this
please representative cor so although um
there
are it doesn't allow people construction
people to
build um without meeting the building
codes of the
towns my concern is that in towns such
as ours where a significant
portion of the
town is in because 65% of our town is
the is
wetland we have strict buffer rules and
to protect the marshes and in the
wetlands and this is not unlike other
towns that have their own conservation
areas and are protecting them for
environmental or Wildlife or um other
reasons
um what do I say how do there there's no
repercussions for building something
where it shouldn't be built and
destroying um
our protected environmental
lands so I don't know
how to incorporate that into this kind
of legislation
but um and although I empathize with the
in you know the UN the uh that in small
towns maybe the building inspector isn't
available or the or the town hall is
closed
or but somehow there has to
well any other thoughts on this section
I mean if I could yeses um I mean they
have to send in the
[Music]
documentation um and there's nothing you
know if if the M if the municipal
officials do respond there's nothing to
prevent that I understand the concern
yeah it does seem to um it does seem to
let them just go on um right and that's
that is is any anyone in the attendees
from the municipal Association or anyone
who could uh speak to us about this
raise your hand if you are a little
disappointed in the lack
of we go as a
previous oh sorry stuck in this weird
spot Margaret burns from the municipal
Association unlike some of
the go ahead M
muted uh thank you everyone good morning
everyone um I admit I am multitasking
and also listening to your work session
here this morning so which which section
have we gotten to here this morning we
are on the section uh section eight
dealing with continuing construction
during
covid-19 sorry page six line 25 yeah
page six line
25 can you hear me a little better now
oh I see so this was a section which I'm
sure you've already discussed here this
morning this was a section that was
added when um construction was you know
construction industry was concerned
about being able to continue or do work
during covid when building inspectors
and building officials um may not be
available to go on site or were City
Hall Town Hall was shut down things of
that nature so this was put in place to
allow construction to continue but also
to put some parameters around it so that
it was still being done safely and and
in good faith and all of those important
things during covid um I have not heard
my understanding at this point is that
cities and towns even if they are doing
you know some hybrid work some remote
work or limiting the public in
City buildings Town buildings that they
are relatively back to normal with these
sorts of operations doing Building
Inspections um certainly they're holding
their planning board hearings and
they're moving forward with things like
that I am not hearing that this is a
concern that they need sort of the the
protection for I don't know if the
construction industry or any of those
folks have a different uh perspective
but I am not hearing the same kind of
concern I did in April of last year when
cities and towns were concerned how they
were going to um help this happen with
with covid and especially in the
beginning when we didn't know exactly
what the right protocol was to keep
people safe so that's that's what I'm
hearing and I'm happy to answer
questions I apologize that I did not
hear your earlier discussion no that's
fine and I appreciate your input Mr BR
Maguire Mr chair I just want to mention
that during the hearing I too heard that
this was no longer necessary that the
emergency order worked for the period it
was needed and that by now it's not it's
not necessary to put it into statute
going forward
so that was said by several people at
the hearing
and I hope we can just delete the
section and not have to worry about it
yeah I to agree thank you it's a couple
sections in this uh omnus legislation
appear to be on the cusp of no longer
being necessary um and this is certainly
one of them unless there's anyone from
the construction industry and the
attendees that would like to weigh in we
will move
along does everyone agree that this
section um we could do away with it
yes
yes right let's I don't see any other
hands raised so we're going to move
along this is a long section I'm glad
we're doing that section nine liquor
licenses and fees expansion of outdoor
dining would like to start this one
looks like it's gonna and have a little
more discussion who would like to begin
say
um now this is just for the Liquor
Commission correct this piece of Li
right as I I heard other legislation
where there was discussion
about
um outdoor dining in general that wasn't
necessarily pertaining to the Liquor
Commission and it seems to me that the
two statutes would have to operate in
be so RSA what's RSA 143 143 a 4 forget
what that is I'll look at
it that's the the existing one then yeah
and the question is does it touch on
right Ian off top of my head I don't
have I don't think the concern is going
to be with the liquor service outside as
much as it's going to be with the zoning
in general outdoor dining issue and that
was dealt with in a separate
bill um anyone have any feelings or
thoughts on this with regard to allowing
The Liquor Commission to extend go ahead
represent
Goen thank you Mr chair I just want to
bring up the point I think we heard from
Environmental Services about expanding
outdoor dining and some issues they had
with that with those that are on septic
systems if I believe this is a section
they testified on I don't think so I
think this is only referring to liquor I
know what you're talking about because I
heard the same testimony I think that
was I think that was in a separate bill
was it 133 that um that would
allow restaurants to open up outside and
kind of he kind of ignored the local
zoning
issues that's correct that was that was
that was that was that bill okay
represent
[Applause]
Maguire no 133 does not deal without
outoor dining this is the section on
outdoor dining we had and I believe the
[Music]
point want to make is that this does not
change any of the local licensing
requirements for example if they have a
capacity limit of a 100 people it
shouldn't matter to their water sewer
systems that those people are sitting
inside or out and I believe that's what
the op is doing is allowing more people
outside because they want
to limit
indoor air loing and allow people to
spread out
further but the locality still have all
the authority they ever did to limit the
number of people in a
facility thank
you 143a colon 4 is um about a food food
um and later on in this section it deals
separately with the uh the liquor
license um but I think what Carol says
it still still applies still the case so
yeah as long as the locality still has
all the authority they originally had to
limit um go ahead representative
gold thank you Mr chair the only the
only other issue I had with this is I'm
not sure
why we need to go through to 2023 um as
we are seeing things are starting to
open up again and uh with the
vaccinations and those uh covid
declining um I would think by the end of
this summer uh
2022 um we should be all set to get rid
of this temporary order and not for all
of next summer as well um I think this
one should end uh through 2022 but
that's just my
opinion only uh push back I would have
on that is that um I I'd like to I'd
like to not to have to revisit this if a
new substrain pops up and if we can give
ourselves a cushion I don't know that it
would necessarily hurt to have it in
there until
2023 um but I understand your point
represent LE yeah I agree with you I
mean I I I certainly hope i' like to
believe that we'll be done with it uh by
the end of the summer end of the year um
but
you know that may not be the case so I'd
be okay I mean I wouldn't object
massively or limiting it to the end of
2022 but I don't have a problem letting
it go through 2023 either unless there's
a reason other than just to keep the
statues clean I would prefer to leave it
to 2023 just so we don't have to revisit
it again if there's an issue and if
everything works out and it's all clear
they're going to probably not utilize It
Anyway representative
gr thank you
s here in my notes Margaret um burn did
say that um although it does recognize
local control she felt that more clearer
language was needed so I'm going to
follow up with her on that unless we oh
I believe she's still here uh Miss Burns
could you uh would you be willing to
chime in on this yes of course um yes
that that is what I uh discussed at the
hearing that the understanding has been
under this language in the governor's
emergency order that clearly local rules
and regulations do apply and that this
language was meant to deal with the
state level licensing allowing for the
outdoor expansion under that statutory
scheme but that all normal local rules
that would apply to you know building
out or making changes in a you know a
site or building out into the road or
unshared property in a parking lot all
of those normal rules would apply and so
my suggestion had been just a few words
clearly saying that you know local rules
and regulations still apply to the
expansion of outdoor dining and I do
after the hearing I did speak with
Darren winham who is um in the planning
director and Community Development
director over in exiter he is the one
who actually drafted this language for
the emergency order and I do believe he
is here with us on the call this morning
so if the committee would would like to
hear a little bit of background from him
on why this was written and what it was
meant to accomplish I believe he's here
with us this morning um he is and I have
promoted him uh Mr winam could you
please let us know your thoughts good
afternoon thank you very much um and
thank you Margaret uh yeah uh I wrote
the legislation but it was with the
assistance of Mike Summers from the L
and Warren Daniels from the spdc and
other a lot of other restaurants uh that
are worried and to just to address a
couple of the issues um the first one is
to The Reason we put it through 2023 and
we originally wrote it through 2022 was
because of the fact that uh these
restaurants are hurting so much and we
want to give them the confidence that
they can actually you know have outdoor
dining for long enough that they are
willing to make investments and you know
uh just be as healthy as they possibly
can be um addressing the environmental
issues uh Margaret's absolutely right
the way the legislation's written as I
understand it is that um you know we
have complete control over that the
towns have control over that now whether
that's on private property or on public
property and it's actually written so
that if one has this is the liquor
portion of it if if a in order to serve
uh liquor outdoors in areas that was not
already approved by Liquor Commission
they have to have the actual Liquor
Commission license so in other words if
a restaurant doesn't have a liquor
license or or for outdoor dining they
can't just get that anyway and the last
piece is is the way most towns do this
the town of course has to approve it as
you understand but then most processes
are like ours there's about six of his
towns that got together and sort of
wrote the drafts for it and that means
one applies to the town the uh the fire
police yeah fire police planning DPW
Health everybody has to sign off on it
and then they get the final signature we
require a million doar of uh
additionally insured if they're on our
property uh and um and that's about it
but it's a very puton down process we
require a sketch and all the department
heads to go see the space and everything
so um very much appreciate you guys
taking this into consideration you're
going to help a lot of people a lot of
workers by doing it thank you um does
anyone else in the committee have any
thoughts or questions um I I think I
like this the way it is it um it leaves
local control but at the state level
takes gets rid of barriers that are in
the way for the restaurants
representative Shu thank you Mr Mr chair
I was curious uh Rob T if from Dees had
testified during the original hearing
and de's concern was um lack
of how shall I say rest facilities to
accommodate possibly um more clientele
I'm curious if Mr tardiff someone from
Dees is
present um I believe we we just stress
that at the beginning because their
occupancy limitations would still apply
so whether they have 100 people inside
or 100 people outside their septic
should be designed for their their
occupancy limits this doesn't wave their
occupancy limits so that should not put
an additional strain on there but
representative gold thank you Mr chair I
I think I'd like to hear a little more
on that because I think occupancy deals
with the inside occupancy when you get
your certificate of occupancy and when
you expand Outdoors that uh number can
be increased because of the square
footage of area You're Now using um but
I would like clarification on that
whether I'm right correct or not Mr
cardish you're uh able to unmute
scen okay I'm sorry about that I think
am I uh I in all right go ahead all
right thank you uh thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee uh again my
name is Rob tarff I'm the administrator
of this subsurface systems program in
the Department of Environmental Services
uh in general we deal with on-site
Wastewater or septic systems uh we deal
with other things but relative to this
conversation I just want to preface what
I'm going to say with we only deal with
those in this case those restaurants
that are on septic systems versus those
restaurants that are on Municipal sewer
for instance so anybody that's on a
municipal sewer we have no Authority or
or any input on that
um what our concern is is a lot of these
properties that the you know that these
restaurants are located on have been uh
the number of seats have been maximized
to what the lot can support and sewage
load uh it's a relatively simple formula
I mean it takes into account uh
different site Char characteristics
whether it be Wetlands uh an on-site
well radius has to be deducted from this
particular formula you plug all this
information in and this formula will
essentially tell you how many gallons
per day a lot can support in sewage load
and the way we regulate restaurants is
on a per seat basis so you know an
approval issued by the bureau may be for
a 50- seat restaurant because that's all
that that lot can support so our concern
is to just allow for additional
seating uh you may get into a scenario
where the lot can no longer buy this
formula support that sewage
load uh the other concerns we have is is
the existing system is designed based on
a particular sewage load and if what I'm
hearing may not this may not apply but
let me I'll just finish my thought here
uh if you add seats you know if you have
a 100 indoor seats or 50 indoor seats
and you want to add 25 additional seats
Outdoors now that that system is no
longer built uh to accommodate for that
additional load the you know it's not
just the leech field that we're
concerned with we're concerned with the
septic tank not being able to separate
the the sewage as it's designed to do in
addition to the septic tank there are
also grease traps and these grease traps
are designed at a particular volume to
address certain grease loads again you
you start accommodating for additional
seating all of that sewage load in
grease and everything else is increased
and it could be increased to a point
where it
could it could cause premature failure
of a
system um and another concern we have is
it's it may be one thing for a
standalone restaurant you know I own you
know Rob tff's restaurant on my own
piece of property and if if I add
additional seating and I fail my system
then it's kind of on me to address that
that situation a lot of these well there
are a number of these restaurants that
are in you know somewhat of a a
condominium a commercial condominium
type scenario where somebody may be the
owner of this commercial condominium one
of his or her tenants is a restaurant so
now that system which is designed to
accomodate for a number potentially a
number of different types of storefronts
including a
restaurant that restaurant may now be
allowed to increase that sewage load
which could detrimentally affect the
system for the entire
commercial condominium
complex um you know we're we're
concerned with you know who who you know
the logistics of how this is going to
happen you know what state department is
going to be uh delegated I guess to keep
track of these seats and if if and when
this gets sunsetted how are those seats
then going to be removed if they're
going to be
removed uh we have existing compliance
at I can I I can stop at any time we we
I don't want to take up too much of your
time one one last thing if I could is we
have existing compliance cases regarding
expansion of restaurants and what would
happen to those existing compliance
cases would that would those compliance
cases then be you know removed from the
from concern so anyway uh again I don't
want to go on and on but uh the
department does have some concerns that
that maybe should be discussed within
the committee thank you uh just briefly
if if a restaurant has a seating
capacity and we're talking about indoor
seating that seating capacity would be
matched to the uh existing sewage system
correct that's correct so if this bill
were to limit the outdoor seating and
indoor seating combined to what the
indoor seating would be would that
alleviate the problem we would have no
issue whatsoever we are under the
impression that this was going to allow
for additional seating as a matter of
fact we if and I'll be brief again but
we have worked with restaurants and we
work very closely with food service
licensing and health and human services
and we have said to people absolutely
bring your seats outside but you would
have to somehow cordon off those indoor
seats as to not increase the sewage load
as a result of bringing seats outside if
if the number of seats don't increase
the subsurface system Bureau has no
concerns thank representative Le right I
that's what I was going to suggest
except it should say they can't have any
more seats than uh currently permitted
for indoor and any pre-existing outdoor
dining because some restaurants have
been able have had both but they may
have expanded the outdoor but I mean an
amendment like that seems like we'll
um we lost oh U Mr winam
please hi thank you very much I
certainly appreciate what Mr tardiff was
saying and I I frankly agree with it
could you possibly uh have it written
such that and I would love to have Mr
tardi way if it's okay have it be that
if it's on AC seed system the way you're
proposing it makes a lot of sense uh
whatever the maximum seats are indoor
and out would be the maximum seats
forever we going ahead till 2023 and
then if it's on Municipal sewer since
it's under Municipal control we could
allow them the extra seats um that it
could be accommodated
so that suggestion sounds sounds right
to you that we just limit it to the
number of combined seats what the indoor
seating would be if you're if you're on
septic but if it's on Municipal then
allow more seating if that's if it's if
the town allows it because you're that's
going to be by Zone and by
yeah
gr right um I want to be sure that one
of the things that's um important about
this legislation is it does allow for
local control which is something that I
want to maintain so um if we put the
legislation
um I'm just wondering
if I I agree with what Mr Charter is
saying that the total number for those
um restaurants who are on septic has to
remain the same as if the indoor
capacity has to equal the indoor and
outdoor capacity
um and for those systems that are on
sewer local we need I think we should
say that local um ordinances local
whatever it is local law applies we I
think we need to say that for both so
that people who are on on sewer
systems understand that they themselves
have to follow local rules as well does
that make sense it it does and um Mr
winham is that not already contemplated
in the bill that at the end of the day
the local
Authority it it is Sir but uh I think
what Margaret and what representative
Gro is saying is that it needs to be I
think more articulated better when I
wrote it I don't think I I wrote it as
well as frankly it could have been okay
representative Gord would you uh be
willing to get us some language that
that would fulfill that what you yeah if
a Mr if Miss is um Burns and Mr Windam
and Mr tff will assist me I'll be sure
to get that to you and then we want to
um so we want to put it so the Max
Capacity then is the um is the uh indoor
capacity so if they go outside they
can't exceed the numb as if they were
all inside does that make sense I've
said this too many times I'm probably
I'll take care of it yep all right thank
you uh representative um goalie did you
uh no I just I just want to point out
that um it would be good to have local
control um still in the mix of it
because it only states that if an
expansion is in a shared space such as a
sidewalker Street then the restaurant
shall be required to coordinate and seek
approval from local authorities uh
doesn't say anything about parking areas
and I think that's an important issue as
well uh in local communities as you take
away parking spaces and you increase
outdoor seating um that increases the
number of cars coming in and those cars
have to park somewhere and if those
spaces aren't there it can become a
problem on local streets um so I think
it is important that local communities
also have a say um in the expansion I I
think they should have the final say um
Mr
[Music]
tar I just wanted to quickly add that uh
I would be more than willing and happy
to to help write any additional language
to this I just want you to know that I'm
on vacation for a week I'll be back next
Thursday I'm leaving tomorrow but I'll
be back next Thursday and again I'd be
happy to help I appreciate the offer um
representative GTO you might want to
take advantage of him today if you could
because I don't think we'll be holding
on to this that long that's right all
right is anyone else have anything to
say on this we're all okay with it if we
fix the um the septic issue and the
issue and that
just I want to recap before we move on
to the amendment so the first section
um want a definition of
temporary everyone said that we would be
correct
twoy
licensing where did we end with that
talking about putting something in about
it being up to the medical board yeah we
didn't really clearly um complete that
but I think that we wanted a definition
of
emergency and there was some discussion
of it
being the declared state of emergency
but also allowing for a local emergency
for lack of medical professionals as
defined by the medical board if they
were to make application to them and if
I recall representative goie wasn't
exactly thrilled with that
idea any other
thoughts chair yes represent didn't um
if memory serves and it's got been a
while now didn't representative Pierce
say that his committee was uh grappling
with this
subject
yes I'm wondering if there's some way
that we could um defer this section to
his committee
which probably has more expertise
do um I'd have to look actually one of
the things is
yeah so
section which section section
two okay
section sunsets then just do it Mr chair
if I may
yes um my my my concerns are um
alleviated s this is going to sunset
January 31st 2022 this is just temporary
and uh as long as it sunsets on the 3
January 31st 2022 I'm all set the way
it's written okay so we'll just leave it
alone and if they need to if they want
to address it further they can take it
up in health and human services and
another
statue um all right so section two we're
three promises and pharmacies um I think
we all agreed that that was fine yeah
and I think that's another one where if
it needs to be expanded be between
Beyond just Co Mo that to the other
committee we're only going to deal with
stuff that's that sunsets and that Co
covers everything else should
appropriately go the right statute uh
section four is the same thing I'm not
sure if that does that sunsets problem
is it's hard of some of these sunset
sunset based on Y and some kind of do
themselves four was testing we agreed
that was fine and it talks about
covid-19 so it sunsets section five was
um vaccinations yeah and we decided to
leave that alone with covid and anything
else if they want they can do in new
legislation
yeah six sunsets as well six sunsets as
state
seven is summer camps we agreed that
that's fine yeah
eight
construction we were talking about
removing that we're gonna we were
talking about removing this section Mr
chair yes go ahead Mr represent B just a
quick one on the summer camps can we
look into whether should sunset or not
that was the other discussion we had on
that one that's the only one yeah I mean
it's it's sort of it's limited duration
but it would still stay in statute if it
doesn't Sunset so yeah that' be good to
do sunset for that and then we all agree
with it
correct all right section eight um the
construction one we I believe we discuss
removing this oh what go ahead one one
other on the summer camps um I think the
somebody we ended up talking about this
uh adding 2020 if they were closed 2020
or
2021 um due to co I mean I'm hoping
that's not going to happen next summer
but there was talk about you know
including 2021 just in case sum well
actually wait a minute I if if they were
closed because of covid last summer and
we could add this summer just in
case but it says covid-19 so it would
have to be because of covid-19 yeah if
we're going to amend it anyway I would
suggest doing that just add year just in
case yeah the summer of 2020 or2 this
we're going to add AET for it like you
said gested representative goalie but
we're going to also include 2021 in case
the summer camp can't open this year
because of CO as
well I'm fine with that else seem okay
all
right section eight we um heard and
agreed that this is no longer necessary
no one's here from the construction
industry to cter that so we're going to
everyone agreed to strike this
portion
okay and unfor which is good so then
that things on section nine
representative gr you're going to get
some language and we all agree that the
language will um limit the capacity for
the source systems to the indoor total
Mr chair I have a
question um so when you say if
everyone's okay with that is that our
version of a vote right now um no I'm
just trying to make sure there's
no okay sorry I'm actually a place where
it's not always easy to hear but I just
wanted to make sure I didn't miss a vote
no just really we're just trying to make
sure there's no more work to be done
before we voted out of the subcommittee
and if you have a issue with anything
speak now
please um and so we agreed on the
language and
nine which I guess so we're all set on
that
um so I guess have to take a vote Mr
chair yes just a quick question um just
a reminder for repres resentative groa
when she works on the uh Amendment for
outdoor dining I think we had agreed
that the um repeal date on that should
be moved up also should she include that
in her uh proposed
[Music]
amendment there was
discussion um some people wanted it
moved up and some left through next year
just in case yeah I think we were G to
leave that through next year just in
case to get we heard from testimony that
uh it would add some shity to the
restaurants as far as planning and and
and things that they knew for sure
they'd be able to continue this
regardless of what happens for one more
year right well it currently if I'm
correct that uh is referred to as
December of
2023 so the suggestion was made make it
2022 right but we agreed that well was
recommended that we leave it the way it
is for
2023 yeah um just so that the
restaurants would have um whether or not
they have to utilize it it lets them
plan and know that they're going to be
able to use this if they have to
question thank you Mr chair I I'm still
just have concerns going that far
forward we're giving them 2021 all of
next year 2022 and then we're looking to
this adds on that third year because
this does end until December 2023 that's
three Summers out I think two summers is
good if we need to expand beyond that we
have the ability to um as needed that
was my only concern I mean this is
going Way Beyond I believe is needed I'm
I believe that uh once the restaurants
have this ability
approved uh that they're going to look
at having this outdoor uh dining
possibility like every
summer which may be a good thing
um bill um so does anyone have an issue
if we bring it to December 2022 no I'm
okay with that and if it looks like in
the fall of 2022 that some Amendment
will be necessary to extend it like
representative Bry said we have plenty
of time to do
that okay can you get that represent BR
just amend change the uh Sunset to
December 2022 versus December
2023 December 2022 we'll do okay so as
far as
um the process here I know certain
people are taking on certain parts of it
are you looking for someone to do other
parts of it or what's the process I
think we've got everything except for
well I need someone could take on the
definition of portion want to do that
for oh for temporary yeah I won't do
that I'd like to get rid of it um but if
you need somebody to take on the summer
that all right um we're not going to
vote on this until we have the the
Amendments um so I'm going to see if I
can get us another subcommittee meeting
shortly because I can't how can we vote
on it without the uh language change I
mean unless we di ational vote based on
what we all agreed to represent goalie
we going to say something I saw you
[Music]
I just was wondering um and this might
be a question for Pam I I think as each
of your subcommittee members are working
on amendments to certain sections um is
a good thing but I think we will need a
full final amendment to amend the whole
bill after we get those initial
subsection amendments done and I just
want to make sure that the committee is
aware of that as well maybe we can send
these to um m
to compile together so we'll have one
amendment to change the bill AB
absolutely I was going to chime in also
Mr chairman thank you um I um would be
happy to you know compile and and look
into the the definition of temporary
health um partner in other states and
and see if I can find some kind of
definition that will be helpful but in
the meantime as you um you know work on
your various pieces if if everybody
would be sure to send them to me that
would that would be
great F question on process from this
smling so should we send a request for
amendments to OSS and then you'll merge
them all together or just send you
something
indicating the changes and what we think
the language maybe should be I I think
it's easier if if we just go to OS once
if possible so if you just send me your
your sort of informal language um you
know clear but but but not necessarily
OS drafted then I can compile it and
send it to them and then review what
they send back to make sure everything's
been Incorporated and I think that's
easier um in the long run okay I think
we got it so um also if Miss Mary if you
could I'll be the one um handling the
the definition of temporary so if you
could get me what you find out on that
sure
sure um representative Schmidt you have
something to
add thank you Mr chairman uh well one
yes uh first of all you guys have done h
a lot of very good work this morning so
congratulations on that uh and well-run
meeting uh but the proposed amendment of
course is still hanging out
there obviously it doesn't go anywhere
uh then uh then then the the process
you've laid out will will wind
everything up
successfully but clearly uh depending on
where we go with the amendment or you go
with the amendment uh we're going to
have to uh no nothing can happen uh with
the with regard the to 155 final form
until that's resolved
so was going to take gonna break you GNA
go right to uh I'm I'm gonna go ahead on
with the amendment right now
okay thanks run out of time and it's
we've got the executive coming up at one
o' I mean the the only other option if
we're going to have another subcommittee
on
155 we address the I'd like to at least
get started onment see where we see
where we land okay so everyone have the
latest Amendment um proposal um 2021
I guess everyone does I'm not seeing
anyone say they don't so
um let's open it up for conversation who
has anything to say about this who wants
to start if he's still there I think
representative Baxter was gonna say
something about his
amendment I don't know if he's still
now
okay representative backer you're you're
live just unmute you
so thank you representative Roy um I am
still here and I really did enjoy that
conversation about s SP
155 um I may want to answer some
questions as they pop up by members on
the committee but I did um revise the
amendment slightly and the biggest
change is the exemption provision um I
really took um the feedback seriously
from the um the last um time when people
were testifying and the exemption
provision was probably the area where we
received the most constructive criticism
so that section's been broadened to deal
with just really medical facilities as a
whole um for an example um we saw
someone from a nursing home that talked
about we don't force our employees to
get the vaccine but we need to know who
has the VAC vacine so we can make proper
decisions for the people we're serving
and I thought that was a very legitimate
criticism so we've taken uh that
feedback and changed the amendment um so
now that exemption provision is broader
um the substance of the amendment
overall is still the same um it's still
a bill that's making sure that um the
state of New Hampshire or businesses
that receive taxpayer funds Don't Force
employees or their customers to get a
vac
or to or to require a vaccine passport
and if they don't do that then they
could possibly be discriminated against
so the substance of the bill is the same
and if anyone has any questions I'm
happy to answer anything right
now anyone have any questions for
representative Baxter or wishing to
comment on the
BR how do um Public Schools fit into
this amendment representative
bter thank you for your question
representative so Public Schools um
because they are subdivisions of the
government they fall under that um so
UNH for example this was asked um last
time they would not be able to require a
vaccine to their students or require a
vaccine
passport Jo all repres
Gord no and I will tell you that I will
not support this
amendment I also will not be supporting
this amendment well it's nice to see
everyone is so open-minded that we can't
even have the
discussion I I do believe that schools
are important component of this and I'm
sorry if this appears to be close-minded
but it is a very important point to me
and I am offended by that comment
representative
shu thank you Mr chair um I've had some
conversation with constituents in my two
towns and the consensus seems to be that
uh they don't feel that it should be
mandated that people show evidence of
vaccine but they also do not feel that
it should be totally banned uh I think
my personal feeling is we should just
leave it alone
leave it up to businesses or entities uh
what they feel they need to make their
employees or clients
safe thank you representative leus thank
you um yeah I've talked with other
people in our district and I the issue
is by saying that people shouldn't have
to have anation showing that they've
been vaccinated and they shouldn't be
forced to it the question is people say
that what do they
be um you know if a
business wants to require um employees
to be
vaccinated I mean does that mean they're
just going to ask them and they'll
answer and and and take that at face
value and if a business more doesn't
want customers in who haven't been
vaccinated you know if there isn't going
to be any document showing you've been
vaccinated what does that even mean um I
mean I'm I'm going to support this I
would actually support it being a
broader as has happened in uh some other
states that uh don't just limit it to
businesses that take money from the
state but it applies to all businesses
um but I mean I'll accept this as a an
acceptable compromise but the key is if
you're going to allow a business
to demand that their employees or their
customers be
vaccinated I mean that doesn't mean much
unless people have to have some kind of
documentation showing it it kind kind of
implies that you're going to have you
know a vaccine passport or something by
another name that's really the same
thing which is prohibited right
so in a sense I mean you could argue
that if uh you know that this actually
should apply to everything um but you
know it is limited somewhat and I'll
accept
that
representative yes thank you uh I second
what representative leus
said look regardless of where you stand
on this subject no matter what
persuasion political or otherwise that
fits you um there's no denying that this
was a highly
politicized circumstance we'll call it
for the past year with that fact
established forcing individuals and it
is forcing forcing them to have a
bioactive compound injected into their
flesh or face societal consequences and
that's what will happen it's an
unbridled attack on our personal
freedoms this is the most important
tidbit of legislation that this
committee is going to consider all year
and I could see it now you you can't
have that job you you can't D in this
establishment you you can't fly out of
this airport you where are your papers
so regardless of complications and I
understand there are
complications uh specifically in the
medic
field we can't provide the means to sort
people like cattle so I support this
amendment and I support broading
it thank you uh representative
[Music]
Maguire have the amendment but I am
actually hopping
in requests that considering how things
are going that you schedule another work
session on this bill before our ex
planed exec session on T next
Tuesday uh if you announce it what day
you choose at this meeting you should be
able you won't necessarily need to put
it in the calendar I believe all parties
are
here you said it you you'd like it to be
before next
Tuesday uh yes Thursday look
empty everyone available Thursday to do
a second work session so we can finish
this
up I am
yeah okay so we're gonna we'll schedule
it for Thursday morning just to wrap
everything up and hopefully we all have
our assigned pieces of legislation back
um okay thank you uh so um I want to
have a chance to speak on that bill if
that's something you moved on from no no
you're talking about the
amendment the amendment and the bill but
right can you hear me yeah um go ahead
representative Schultz I just want to
say you know um first of all there is no
vaccine passport that is a a word that
is loaded and nothing anyone is asking
for on the second piece to expand requ
you know disallowing requiring a
vaccine
um I don't think we should be
telling any
should require it's iic because I
believe it's un wedding cake uh you
cannot tell a business Bakery they have
to be able to make a wedding cake for a
same gender
couple um this would actually be the
same we
can't
Telles Schulz you're coming in and out
I'm only getting like a quarter business
or institutions as far as I understand
it
actually okay let me how about is it
better this way it's just can you hear
me better now yeah so far you haven't
cut out again but I go ahead well just
one more uh thing I wanted to say about
it and that is it actually very well may
hinder uh business because if it is a
tourism related business that wants to
[Music]
en safety for those who have been
reluctant to travel
uh the ability to require a vaccine say
if we were to have a port in Portsmouth
for a cruise ship or buses from cruise
ships or uh which does happen by the way
from Boston and Portland or any other
that to ensure the safety of their
employee or our opinion is about the
vaccine if a business has decided that's
what they need for the safety of their
employees and their customers that
shouldn't be something ironically that
we should want to uh do I just find it
ironic that our values about uh the free
market change when we have a personal
opinion over a vaccine or an illness
which by the way none of us are Health
Care uh providers to have an opinion on
that
but
right okay uh thank you representative
Schulz um I think you I think we just
lost you again but I got your last
statement um I was finished yeah thank
you thanks um let me see uh committee
Members First representing groa are we
gonna continue or we going to do one oh
actually well it's 12 o'clock is it one
one
o'clock we have to one Mr chair I will
hold my question until we meet again
it's fine
if there's no issue
yeah break for lunch to
one can I can I interject briefly Mr
chairman just um before you all go I
understand you're as I understand it
you're talking about representative
Baxter's Amendment
1334 correct that's correct and I just
want to point out that it it amends and
I didn't maybe you talked about this and
I I missed it but it amends section six
of the bill relative to the farm
Pharmacy language and also section nine
of the bill on the expansion of outdoor
dining and I just want to you know you
to keep that that in mind as as further
amendments um are discussed to either of
those parts did that did did the does
this amendment alter those yes yes it it
does so you know if we're thinking about
adopting it you know as 1334 we just
need to remember that those sections
appear and if you want to do something
different with the expansion of outdoor
dining potentially we need to get a new
amendment that only addresses the
vaccine anyway just just to keep it in
mind to keep it in play oh thank you and
I appreciate you keeping just a process
question I what I thought was that if we
if the committee uh votes to adopt this
as well as another amendment you know
dealing with various parts of SP 155
that the end result would then be merged
together in one Amendment just like
we're doing for 133 and so there' really
only be one amendment in the end is that
not correct that's what we're that's
what our goal is to have one Amendment
but but I just wanted to make sure that
you know if you adopted 1334 and then
you adopted something that
representative grota put together that
amended the expansion of outdoor
dining you know they would potentially
conflict so I just want to make sure
that we adopt you know one
change each section we don't have to as
a process we don't have to adopt this
proposed amendment we can adust adopt
the language we want right I mean you'll
you'll fold this into the final big
Amendment and if you say let's not deal
with the expansion of outdoor dining
portion of the backer Amendment let's
let Gro to you
know language take take precedence
that's fine I just want to make sure I
understand what you're
no um no I understand so we we will we
will look at that and make sure that and
did you get um what I discussed with
representative Maguire as far as a
further subcommittee on this on Thursday
morning at 10 if possible I did hear
that I will be um in another committee
at the same time so it it it makes it um
difficult to to listen to
both but that's what I've been doing
today too so but is that available for
us to use I don't know I'm not um the
person in charge of the the licenses you
have to get permission from Aaron
goulette okay all right thank you um
let's just wrap up real quick for for
this one I want to give everyone a
chance to speak on the um to speak on
the uh Amendment with regard to the
vaccines because um after this uh I
we'll probably just vote on it at our
next meeting I don't I don't want to
belabor it um representative Gord did
you already you already spoke on the
vaccine Amendment portion
correct she said she
defer I said I would defer I also want
people to know that I'm not man I don't
I'm not agree I don't support mandating
vaccines but I support local control as
to what they do okay all right thank you
um representative
Shu thank you Mr chair um
I will just point out that we do have uh
an interstate airport in this state I
don't see how it we could possibly
mandate to Southwest Airlines whether
they feel they need to ensure that every
customer that comes on their plane uh
has vaccine since they're flying to
other states that will mandate that I
know for a fact um they have been
requesting proof of testing previously I
haven't flown recently but I believe
that that's probably what's coming so I
don't see how we can do that with an
airport that um obviously flies to other
states and possibly other
countries well without addressing um
without addressing your the sentiment I
can tell you that having just come back
from Florida on Southwest they required
nothing other than a mask there was no
requests for vaccinations or anything
like that
um
representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman so I
understand that we're up against the uh
one o00 uh schedule uh and for a break
for lunch uh but uh so in my view there
are several aspects of this uh proposed
amendment the new one the new new
variant uh that are completely
unworkable uh some would be in violation
of federal statute I believe uh
and just reminding that uh that we we
cannot bind a future legislature uh and
so to the degree that we are proposing
to ban something which is not on the
table vaccine passports are not on the
table uh state or government mandates of
of vaccination are not on the table uh
so we might as well include you know
flying pink elephant or unicorns as well
uh is ter in terms of the workability of
this
amendment I will speak to it at length
when when we have an opportunity but
you're intending to take this up at 10
o'clock on Thursday morning again Mr
chairman um actually no the next time
you'll be able to speak about this
probably be in full committee no I
thought we were having a subcommittee
work
s
know I'm sorry we can't hear you m yeah
that you you could that be repeated I
[Music]
it
so had a chance to speak on this I don't
I don't recall I mean all all I'll say
is that the word vaccine passport may be
loaded um I'll admit that but if we're
going to permit I mean if there's going
to be a requirement either by the state
or by private businesses in effect you
create something like a b vaccine
passport whatever you want to call it um
and certainly if you're if it ever is
required to fly then it's basically what
it is um the only thing I'll say is um
there are more than one state that have
already passed the law completely
prohibiting any business from requiring
it and I don't know of any state that
doesn't have an airport that has flights
out of the state so um you know this is
there's going to be a larger issue there
and there's going to be some
accommodation to it I believe um anyway
I mean I think it could be a larger
discussion but right so that that's my
was my question are we further
subcommittee meeting uh at which this
will be thoroughly vetted because we
haven't done that at this
time we will um whatever's left to be
done at the next subcommittee uh meeting
with regard to this we will okay so
that's going to be on Thursday morning
at 10 o' Mr chairman that's what I'm
trying to determine that's correct um
although I don't want to I don't want to
spend an inent amount of time on a on an
amendment that we already kind of uh
Lear on as far as voting um I would just
I'm going to close uh this meeting
myself um with my final comments um I
think that the state of New Hampshire um
has a tradition of person Liberty um I
would be against any mandated
immunizations any mandated records of
immunizations or any government or
private entity um demanding proof of
immunization I think it's um you know we
say that we
don't we we're ironically picking you
know what we want to interfere with well
this is a constitutional right to
privacy that the the people of New
Hampshire just voted on in the last
election that they hold their privacy to
be very dear to them and you cannot get
any more priv than someone's medical um
situation so um I think that the the
constitution of the State of New
Hampshire supersedes that um so I will
be voting in favor of this in some form
or fashion um as we delve into whether
or not any amendment to it as necessary
so with that I'm going to close this
hearing and I will see the members of
the subcommittee again on Thursday
morning at 10 o'clock after we hopefully
if we get this Zoom stuff sorted out for
that time and with that we're going to
go ahead and close this subcommittee
meeting and everyone please remember
that at 1:00 there will be an executive
session um we'll be picking up again on
133 I thank you all very much and thank
you thank
you m Mar if you could meet the room or
we'll do it you gonna do
it okay I'll let you do
notice
really
joh
[Music]
promise mine wasn't working right thank
computer
me
sure
we are short a few members of the
committee
uh a
Pam yes what I'm going to do if it's
okay with you is to continue the process
of uh uh committee work session and
write up a separate uh committee report
on each subsection put them together so
you you have separate
items each one makes sense each section
is separate makes sense yeah since we
only
have you know four sections that haven't
yet been
addressed okay well just add it to the
previous I guess that's yeah that's the
way I was doing it before and right all
thanks
here there you are piar
here
[Music]
phone
and while we're waiting for people to
settle in um I don't know if you saw oh
you did representative Maguire that the
the note from Miriam about potentially
starting Thursday's work session at 9:30
or
10:30 I sent it back back to him because
it's his sub committee it's up to him
okay so I'll wait to hear from
representative
Roy I'm here 9:30 would be fine if
that's what we need to do okay great
thank
you
[Music]
looks like almost everybody is
here so uh Welcome to our presumed
executive session on Senate Bill 133 we
have four sections left
14 here and I think I will start on 14
because I like to get that one there
representative bred do you have a motion
do we want to take attendance oh yes
pardon me you don't do we need to speech
either yes Miss Marling do I need to
give the
Spiel I think it's it's always safer
have
okay as chair of the house Edna
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
first went to executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet remotely this is an executive
session on Senate Bill
133 please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I'm confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if invited participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available through the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and RSA 91
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS ledge. state. n. Us in event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call votes we'll start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states their presents please
also state
there's anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required
under the right to
know representative Allegro here in the
room representative Bailey present in
fellows not yet I guess uh
representative font no I am present and
my wife is in the house with me
representative
goalie at home and my wife is in the
other
room representative
broa I am in my home office and I am
alone representative
Judy I am in my studio music my wife
she's
downstairs representative
lenara Hi H and NASA and some family
around representative Le
present in the committee room
representative Maguire present in the
committee room representative
O'Brien I am president I am a home in
Nashville and I am alone representative
Pearson I am in my office at our Medical
Center in Kingston and I am alone
representative
Roy I am here I'm in my truck um at some
point my son will be joining
me representative
santonastaso I'm here alone in
Schmidt I am present in my home office
in Dober and I'm alone representative
sh I am present at my home in Pembrook
alone representative
Schultz hi I am in my residents and
conquered and my husband will be in and
out of the room including now clks in
the room representative
yakovich present at home alone in the
room and we will try representative
time uh please alert me if you see her
before I do thank you I don't no
representative fellows at this time than
full house
otherwise
So the plan for today is to do the vote
on the four sections we have not yet
voted on and then recess so that uh we
can have our researcher come together
with a comprehensive Amendment to the
bill so representative on section 14
[Music]
Amendment you'll have to unmute yourself
Jackie thank you um thank you uh yes I
move a to pass on um representative wner
non- gerain agree uh Amendment regarding
the um
daycare hours required second CHR SCH
okay's representative fellow okay
representative
fell um pres at home
alone terrific thank you sorry I was at
a senate
meeting I'll be GL second okay El that's
fine oh I did also could you not hear me
second but I'm fin with representative
Le this that's fine you're you're being
inaudible
Chris some people's dream can you hear
uh would you like me to speak to my
Amendment Madame chair speak please
thank you this amendment addresses the
um need for uh immediate need for
daycare workers in our state and um
representative walner who is from that
industry um and representative MC
Williams who is um also an advocate for
daycare both support this amendment and
I support it for the reasons that we
need daycare workers in um immediate
need for daycare workers so that we can
get our young families back to work the
work um I have nothing further to add I
think that covers it yes uh since we're
since we're being less formal than usual
represent peric I got some language
from Melissa Clemens at the licensing uh
office and she suggested that it that
the documented life
experience shall it shall include
experience of the same age
children because uh she thought that
that was very an important distinction
and and I would agree with her would you
agree to modify your Amendment with that
uh that language yes I will I'll I'll
meeting represent L you're okay yes I've
uh it makes perfect sense that if you're
if you know how to deal with a a
12-year-old you may or may not know how
to deal with a two-year-old
nobody knows
that thank you representative Schmidt
for that insight for your vast agent
experience repres I'd like to say that's
the other shoe that dropped
because um Miss Clement wanted to say
something after we had finished and we
did not she did not get an opportunity
and I think that's what she was up to so
that's kind of nice to yes sent me a
note and um and she pointed this out and
I I agreed with her on that issue and so
bringing it Forward May point out my
tenants would like to hear this
is yes
okay all right is there any further
discussion on this this amendment which
would be become section
14 Madam chair yes represent sh yes can
you we just clarify that this is
um amending the language of Amendment
1162 is that correct yes it was the
basic change to add some specificity for
the life experience was approved by the
subcommittee this language came in after
the subcommittee and representative
Broda has just accepted it thank you I
just thought we should make it clear
what what specific Amendment we are
adding language
to yes I am certainly hoping that we
will get a real honest to God numbered
amendment in time for all of us to read
it schedule is that next
Tuesday there's a work session in the
morning and we will have a final
executive session in the afternoon and
we should have all our final amendments
at that point I hope thank you site
representative Le you second you go
along with the uh he said so already I'm
sorry I did not hear that okay is there
anyone else who wishes to speak on this
Marin I'm sorry I was just typing I I
just want you to know that it's in the
draft as you just adopted it as you just
spoke about it so I'm I'm with youed yes
I'm glad it's it's youve got
everything Madam Cher I just wanted
therefore
understand that Miss Marling is going to
in input is going to put this language
into her final Amendment and that I do
not need to contact OS is that correct
no one needs to contact OS on any of the
Amendments at this point we will be
getting a final committee amendment that
includes all the bits and pieces okay
very
good right anyone else wish to discuss
discuss this
comments
questions well if Pam could fix the
participants
list uh where it shows executive
departments instead of the individual
that would be a little bit helpful
keeping track of who's here and
not yes thank you I did a couple and a
few people went and corrected the uh
their names to be more
proper right we just need to know who um
the gentl are representative
oh is the
is they all entered the RO yeah they
entered the r they're Pro they're
here okay so if if um that last person
who's not showing themselves would just
is
yes anyway we'll find out okay any
amendment okay no hands up no no voices
is
amendment I believe the non gerain
Amendment to the
amendment it's
gerain well two votes one for the
language yes one we two votes one for
the language chains made by the
subcommittee and one to adopt the
amendment as part of the
B yes
is that wait a minute aren
they you mean the section is part of the
bill yes uh Miss Marling help do we need
this um I don't think you really do as
long as everybody is clear um what
you're voting on you're you're taking
the
walner uh MC Williams Amendment but
changing that adding a a new sentence to
the end of the subparagraph n which was
the Melissa Clement
language I hope everybody got the email
that that outlined that yesterday and
clear
okay that case we we will have one vote
to incorporate the this amendment under
discussion into Senate Bill 133 as
section
understand speak now for hold your peace
and the cler can the representative Roy
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative Alro yes representative
Bailey yes representative lonara yes
representative Santo naso yes
representative goalie yes representative
sh yes representative Judy we
representative
Schmidt yes representative
Schulz yes representative fellows yes
representative fno
yes representative groa yes
representative O'Brien yes the chair yes
and we're looking 190 on the adoption of
excellent covich York subcommittee had a
recommendation on Section six the music
motion
I'm sorry madam chair I didn't I didn't
hear all this what this is for SE I'm
sorry can you repeat that part yes I'm
calling on representative kubovich to
make a motion on Section six licensure
regulation of Music therapists from the
sub committee I motion to itl this
second
Madame chair are we not going to
consider the the amendment that I sent
to you that I was sent to the committee
no not not unless we vote down un unless
the itl is
lost second the did you get
that I we had several other people did
at the same time and so okay second um
was algro algro is second who who moved
it y of
course do you care to speak to your
motion um yes we've discussed this
matter previously in the committee few
months back and I don't believe at this
you I have nothing to add we've
discussed this pretty much at L already
so thank you yes I will mention that uh
House Bill 209
was uh moved itl and not voted on so
position Madam chair if I may yes
represent the issues that this committee
discussed concerning this amendment had
to do with the fact
that
um the some of the considerations from
the previous bill had not been
considered as well as the
um harmonization of the language between
the music therapist and Asha and all
this has been accomplished in an
amendment that I said that was submitted
to the committee and a lot of work was
put on this on this and I would imagine
I would hope that when you people vote
today they will consider
representative
Roy I would just um ask representative
Gorda because I'm not familiar with the
amendment is it anything new that we
haven't already discussed regarding
music therapists in the previous uh
months ago and last year regarding the
lure of Music
therapists yes thank you for the
question there was a disagreement in the
language or there was a disagreement in
how music therapists versus um speech
therapists did their work and how their
territories were going to be carved out
and this has been agreed upon between
the two organizations on the na on the
national level and this language was
sent to me and miss miss chesterly who
was an a represented the a
uh stood with who who had not supported
the amendment now supports the amendment
has withdrawn her protests which I think
is a significant
change thank you for the question
representative
Schultz yes Madam chair thank you I
appreciate the hard work that
representative groda and others have
done to um have that level of work and
and compromise I think we need all the
tool all the the tools we need in the
toolbx should be available and I think
if we um itl this um I do think that
this will leave music therapy only
available to um those who can afford it
and I think that is a
shame thank you for that that position
anyone else
[Music]
um the uh Amendment clearly would make
the bill better and if the bill goes
forward I would vote for the amendment
because it clears the areas of
uh areas practice the trouble is as I
said in my parliamentary inquiry when
this came up last session and perhaps
this will eventually
survive Edna is charged with public
health and safety not
desirability or or the path or ironing
out the path taking the first step down
the road of insurance
reimbursement if we change
our Charter or if that happens and it's
a question that it's proper for us to
consider this in so that uh we get they
can get insurance
reimbursement okay but that's not our
Charter they do have right now
certification uh there is a National
Organization that attests to their
credentials so I I'm unhappily not
supporting this because they're good
people but that's not our charge
and so there I am
excuse me let me just please finish with
this I don't I cannot see a credible
threat to public health and safety if
this is unlicensed I just I've heard
that but I I it's just it's just not
believable to me and now I am finished
goolie thank you madam chair I will be
voting against the itl I think it's
uh a big accomplishment that these two
groups have come together uh with
language that they both can support uh
going forward and I think it delineates
what the two practices can and cannot do
and um so I'm hoping that uh we can
defeat the itl so that this uh amendment
can be considered and hopefully adopted
thank you represent
Pearson thank you madam chair um as most
of you know I chair the Health and Human
Services Committee of the house and
we've looked at this kind of issue but
what you probably don't know is since
age 16 I was a have been a professional
Church musician directing choirs and
playing the organ and every once in a
while I it has been my experience and
the experience of other people like me
where music can be a wonderful help in
many ways to people but when we look at
professional music therapists um I have
a a big red flag raised and we are on
page 38 lines 25 and following of at
least the bill as it's uh located on the
House website the practice of music
therapy it says does not include the
screening diagnosis or assessment of any
physical mental or communication
disorder uh that is quite different from
the therapists I know including um art
therapists and others um if you cannot
diagnose something that is wrong if you
cannot screen for it if you cannot give
it a
descriptor um that's just leaving good
folks who are Musical and use their
music to help people who may need a
little bit of help in other words this
is either too much or too little and I
really don't see the need for such uh a
section as this to go
forward
thank you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chairman well uh
we are definitely talk talking about the
health of young children I've been in
this one of the establishments in Dover
that happens to be in my district uh and
they deal almost exclusively with young
children uh and they're not just playing
music to them by any means uh this is a
recognized uh profession and special
uh the language that representative
Pearson just alluded to uh is to
differentiate them from speech
pathologists and
audiologists who are uh medical
professionals not necessarily mental
health uh Specialists so uh because this
is a profession that we are not the
first to recognize by any means uh I
think that uh we should uh
definitely act on behalf of uh
children's better mental health and I
will be voting against the itl as
Judy
son
Judy oh I'm sorry Madame chair I'm
really sorry yes uh members of the
committee um music uh make a difference
in people's
life for
example uh when I get involved in the
accident 1990
[Music]
93 they try everything for me
mentally but uh a friend of mine
starting
uh playing
music for me and then he he was in the
for he was in New York City I I was here
in New
Hampshire uh that make a big difference
in my life and after three or four
session he not a therapist but we grow
up together in ha we we used to play
soccer and he
knows he want to do something in my life
and then he start playing music he play
guitar he play drums he play organ and
uh after months I feel
difference I have uh I have that in my
mind since 9 until
today uh I'm going to vote against this
itl because music can make big
you thank you madam chair um I believe
that during the original Bill even we
heard testimony that uh through the use
of
Music uh some of these folks have been
able to reach uh particularly Disturbed
autistic children and uh Alzheimer's
patients uh representative scitec if
that's not somewhat healing um I don't
know what would be thank you I will be
itl thank you madam
chair music therapy is used
for people who have
who have executive function
disorders um who are artist who are
autistic who have cognitive uh function
dis disorders this is not um this is
used as a way of reaching those those
people and helping
them learn
different a new a different way to learn
than the conventional way that those of
us who don't have those
dysfunctions learn so I think that it's
an important
consideration
for as a group of
therapy and it's just not about
listening to music and playing music
thank you I think that we we all know
that having heard testimony and seeing
year I'd like to say that I'm delighted
that the
audiologists have the speech language
ologists have worked out their conflict
with the music therapists because there
are music therapists in the state and
they are able to work um as
representative Schmidt has testified
they have a center in his
town the issue is do they need to be
licensed and that's an entirely
different matter than is music therapy a
good thing and so that's that's the
point that we're voting on is should
they be
licensed and is there anyone else who
speak
there's representative Pearson and then
representative
Broda I do very much appreciate the
positive comments made on the use of
music to help people uh my concern is
that uh since they are not involved in
screening or diagnosis or assessment uh
which is often what various licensed
board certified board licensed
professionals do uh certainly we can
have music therapists in the state to
our profit the question is really do we
need to license them and that's why I
support the itl I don't think we do I
been thank you madam chair the purpose
of the lessons is to support the
training that these individuals go to
there are specific courses and specific
training and specific degrees that are
geared towards that and one would hope
that we would support that so that the
individuals who tell themselves as music
therapists are actually licensed music
therapists and have taken the necessary
courses and have the necessary knowledge
to address
cognitive learning skills thank
you represent
sh to representative Pearson's point and
I do think it's a good one there are
other aspects of the medical field that
we license that do know diagnosing of
any kind like RNs psychiatric RNs uh
lnas there are multiple
um health care providers that don't
diagnose I don't see that for me as a
reason to not license them I think that
they have
demonstrated the proper level of
professional
professionalism and a need for our
citizens to have access to licensed
professionals as recognized by the
granite state so I will still be voting
against
itl leus uh thank you madam chair uh I
heard concerns about making sure
that people to present themselves as
music
therapists have appropriate training
it's my understanding that there's
already a
certification available through National
Organization and if someone's wants to
know whether or not you know the music
therapist they're considering
hiring has appropriate training they can
ask for that certification I don't see a
license U representative Schultz uh the
people you just referenced as not doing
diagnosis can have a direct effect on
somebody's health or
safety uh I don't see that I'm a nurse
with improper medication or other
applying wrong therapies can do real
harm it is hard for me to believe as I
had said
earlier why am I wasting everyone's time
I suppose that um how this can actually
be injurious that the public needs to be
protected when there is u a level of
certification available look I lose the
debate every day on its Effectiveness or
its
desirability I think I win the debate on
public health and
[Music]
safety that note of Triumph well
it's is there anyone else who wishes to
say
something
all right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate which will leap
this section from Senate Ville
133 CL will call the RO
represent yes cler
yes representative Pearson
yes representative
yakovich
yes representative leus yes
representative bro yes representative
Bailey yes representative lanara yes
representative Santo Miss
Paso are you there he's there
yes representative goalie no
representative
representative Schmidt sorry no
Schultz
no representative fellows no
Representative fno
no representative Broda no thank you
representative
O'Brien no and the
chair yes it is
109 than to say
[Music]
209 all
right
[Music]
professionals
your
motion I I'm I'm looking for the section
47 can somebody else make the
motion
right I'll move in expedience legisl
which I believe was recommendation
of I
you I'll say that it's first it was the
recommendation of the
subcommittee
and after that that meeting the several
people approached me on the issue
and
we agreed after a few rounds of
discussion that it was not really
fellows from uh listening to the
discussion about that it seemed to me as
if maybe um the senate had good
intentions but didn't realize that it
would actually severely restrict the
number of people who could make that
assessment
exactly represent Pearson thank you
madam chair this was one of the sections
that was sent over to me um as chairman
of Health and Human Services I uh spent
some time discussing this with the
Department of Health and Human
Services and there was an accusation
that unless we restrict it to registered
nurses anybody off the street including
the janitor can make a diagnosis but
what's in place presently is the
strikeouts so it talks about in line 29
an individual with equivalent training
designated by the department and they
said their present practice is to do
exactly that they don't have their
secretaries or their janitors make these
diagnosis but to restrict it to
registered nurses which line 32 would
have us do would significantly up the
cost without providing any better um
quality of product because the again the
operative phrase in line 29 is an
individual with equivalent training
that's what they do now they haven't
found difficulty with that to restrict
it to nurses would hamper the work that
they're doing in various places so um
I've talked with others in the medical
field as well and the consensus I heard
was leave it as it is you take out
section eight it reverts to what it was
which is the strikeouts
thank
concerns right seeing none the motion is
itl which is remove this section from
Senate Bill
133 and I'm Ready the clerk will call
the
[Music]
roles
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative algro yes representative
Bailey yes representative lanzara yes
representative Santo naso yes
representative
goie yes representative Shu yes
representative Judy
we representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative fno yes representative
groa
yes representative O'Brien yes and the
[Music]
zero section 12 T tele medicine provided
psychologists you have a motion I have a
motion with the amendment to otpa with
an amendment sent by
Pam okay good
morning
so which that amendment
[Music]
is there are two of
them
um which amendment do you choose um 8
morning just just to confirm Madam chair
is that the uh amendment that uh Dr
Warner requested me to put in I don't
know representative Schmid because I
also had one that I put in on the
benefit from opl C which is somewhat
different from yours but um we might we
need to know which one
representative which means before we
decide which is the one we should be
discussing this is the oplc draft
legislation okay 5321
LBC 803 this morning I help to write
representative Schmid and I will second
the
motion
we have yes they're they're both here
out you wish to speak to your motion uh
sure yeah this is the oplc amendment um
as Pam stated it's been created with
consultation with Lindsay
Courtney so this is the want to I would
like to move forward thank
you yes and I will
uh speak to this I
helped discuss
it I asked Lindsay to write it once we
when we're discussing it the issue is
that at the moment approximately
two-thirds of the the psychologists
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
have temporary or emergency
licenses and the reason and they have
not had any success in converting those
to permanent
licenses anecdotally this includes
people who live in New Hampshire but
practice in Massachusetts or Vermont
rain because they didn't get a license
there and even though the requirements
are on paper almost identical they can't
seem to get a New Hampshire psychologist
license so what this amendment does it
allows it requires a
license a person with a
temporary license to practice or an
emergency
license that has worked in the state for
at least 90 days in good standing and
completes the application and pays the
Fe and is promoted to a full Hampshire
psychologist license which by Statute
specifically allows them to practice
tele
medicine and I think that makes a lot
more sense than trying to create a new
level of
license since we all
that since
the the ACT required as part of a
regular
license so I would hope that we can
eliminate the bottleneck at the board
which is what I think the issue
is and representative L just to help me
that this continues allowing this
uh anybody who's got a temporary
emergency license can
get certain requirements can get a good
practice what does this do to deal with
the bot
it's at the back flip it over on on the
back number
four it says not withstanding any other
provision of law to the contrary the
office of professional license or
certification shall issue a
license the board of psychology seems to
want to
and
data from
your supervised practice when you
beginning school transcripts which are a
even um okay so the bottle is is getting
people the emergency licenses it's not
just the normal status of somebody
applying for a license under normal
times no the emergency licenses are
days the pro the thing is that what this
would do would allow someone the
bottleneck is getting a permanent full
psychologist license sure I guess which
is under the control board rather than
the appeal so I assume the the temporary
or emergency licenses are they are they
going away after the state of emergency
or will they continue and if they're
going away
this might provide an initial group of
people getting permit licenses but is it
going to help going
forward uh temporary and emergency
licenses are already in statute for
psychologists it is not based on an
emergency order it's only the emergency
license that is granted by the oplc that
is an emergency
workorder but there are um
329b Cola 20 already deals with
licenses thank
else um Madame chair I was trying to
raise my hand
but me I do have a question about the
amendment so the amendment strikes out
tempor in the in line I'm not sure it's
the beginning of the amendment it
strikes out temporary and
emergency and replaces it with
applicants from other
states and then at the
bottom it says section four
notwithstanding any other provision of
state law to the
contrary um it starts with this is the
first point is a the individuals has
practiced in New Hampshire under a
temporary order emergency license so how
does
um how do these things do these things
not sound conflicting to you I'm sorry
do these things I missed that last part
so sorry the the section A where it says
the strike out of the title of this
section which is Strikes Out temporary
and emergency just talk refers refers it
to applicants from other
states and then section four of the
Amendment the very bottom says that uh
oplc shall issue a license to practice
psychology or school psychology to any
individuals who have met the following
requirements and it says a the
individual is practiced in New Hampshire
under a temporary or emergency license
for a period of at least 90
days where does this refer to a
different part of the bill yes said BR
if you if you look back on the beginning
part Roman one is a person licensed to
practice psychology in another
jurisdiction can apply for a license and
it gives you the requirements for
that uh Roman two and that would be
temporary lure if you look down there
under
1e so this is an individual seeking
temporary
license so Roman one is how you get a
temporary license number two is a
declared person licensed in another
jurisdiction providing services and
response to declared
disaster I see I see excuse me of course
okay I get I understand yeah three is a
temporary practice is for for somebody
that's it talks about all all of the
goalie thank you madam chair I I was
actually going to bring up the same
questioning about striking temporary and
emergency applicants uh in regards to
this so I think with that uh being said
I am all
comments
answer uh fellows yeah I'm just I'm just
kind of confused because I was on the
subcommittee for um
133 and we discussed the tele medicine
part of it but I don't have remember any
discussion about what this amendment is
about
did did I just forget it or was it
discussed in a different subcommittee or
what discussed in a different
subcommittee at the public hearing on
133 during this section representative
Lindsay oh not representative director
Lindsay was saying that this is
a they weren't really in support of this
because they didn't think it was
entirely necessary because their statute
already has emergency and temporary
licenses which would allow them to do
tele
medicine it was I don't believe that
came up during the
recall so so does the amendment is it
tacked on to the end or is it
replacing what is now section in the in
12 so I just feel a little uncom
comtable that we didn't hear testimony
on this amendment at least I
didn't another subcommittee did or no no
this was a it came out of a private
discussion that I was having with the
director op
PLC because and I asked her what she
meant by not thinking section 12 was
necessary and she pointed out that they
had this and were talking about how many
emergency licenses they had and I said
well what we really need is a way to get
the emergency licenses converted into
full
licenses and therefore came up with
assignment okay okay thanks you I I
understand and and I feel uncomfortable
with going ahead with something that's
so different that didn't get a public
goalie thank you madam chair so is it my
amendment replaces section 12
completely
yes I'm sorry that wasn't clear yeah
because it just says to include the
um all right thank
you
and can I just um interject Madam
chairman with the effective date of this
amendment be July 1st 2021 as it was as
it is currently for part
um
12 thank you Miss Marling I was just
gonna point that out
okay
no unless someone has some objections I
think that makes sense
because we do have like I said 2third of
questions right seeing
none motion is to adopt the amendment
under
and will fall the role Madam chair yes
representative shua yes will will this
amendment uh incorporate that effective
date at the bottom as the original bill
has that's the kind of thing that that
our I just wanted to be sure that that's
understood while when we vote Yes
call we're talking about the opl
so-called
oplc we've been discussing okay
representative
Roy
yesos yes representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative Alro yes representative
Bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative Santo naso
yes representative
goalie yes representative
sh yes representative Judy we miss
representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz yes
representative
fellows no
representative font no yes
representative Gro yes representative
O'Brien yes the chair
yes 18
[Music]
to1 I'm
impressed uh all right that takes care
of the last section of Senate Bill
and M Marling how uh how soon do you
think we can get the
amendment I think I can have it um
cleaned up and sent if if you'd like to
review it first I can send it to you um
or I can send it directly to OLS I I
would have to ask them um how long it
would take so much depends on how tied
up they are with the budget and and
everything else right so probably not
today then oh definit I feel confident
that it would not be today okay in that
case the further schedule is that there
are work session scheduled for this
coming Thursday the 13th on Senate B
155 and is there another one as well
have 104 and let's see other and
yes those are so no those are the final
work sessions of those and then there is
a executive session in the afternoon of
Tuesday and I hope we'll be able to vote
out all four of these
bills what what I have is is 9:30
subcommittee on Tuesday the 18th for 58
and and Senate Bill 104 and then 10:30
executive session is that not I believe
that
uh I very I'm suggested we make it one
o'clock through the executive session
and I think that makes
sense okay I did not see
that in any event we'll if it's we'll go
with what's in the calendar and do the
subcommittees so do you want to add
anything to the
subcommittees is everything scheduled
not all all three bills other than 133
have a subcommittee scheduled
okay and 133 we will we should have the
exact
cred representative
yakovich yeah uh on this Thursday um
something I got a notice for 9:30 a.m.
but well I got a panelist invitation but
no notice over the subcommittee can you
please tell me which subcommittee that's
the subcommittee on Senate Bill 155 and
its non derain
Amendment right and that went to the
full Committee just to cover all bases
if if you're interested in attending um
so it it wasn't just limited to
subcommittee members to be all inclusive
you know but you're
that is the only um scheduled meeting
the subcommittee work session on 155 and
who are the committee members then
what's that who are the committee
sorry the chair representative Roy me
Chris schz and Tony laas and Lara and
lonara thank you all right oh Madam
chair did you not say the subcommittee
on Senate Bill
104 meeting on Thursday this Thursday
also I may have said it but I believe
that's actually meeting on Tuesday
representative Pearson's two bills that
is 58 and 104 are meeting on Tuesday
right I thought you had just stated 104
a few seconds ago I might have but I was
wrong okay thank you no you said the
18th Carol okay yeah that's next Tuesday
correct and then we will follow that
subcommittee
which if I interpreted the what I heard
over the zoom correctly they should just
be looking at the final Amendment and
blessing it because they had
reached agreement in
principle all right
repres
just I have a question Madam chair uh in
subcommittee this morning it was stated
that the uh the subcommittee meeting on
Thursday morning would be at 10 o'clock
but the hour of 9:30 was just mentioned
so which is it going to be 9:30 that's
convenience of our research who who has
two other places to be at 10 o'clock I I
recall her mentioning that so 9:30 I I
will make a note thank you Vera you have
question I do I just want to make sure
that um as right as as we're um making
motions to these
subcommittee um I mean these subsections
of the of these bills are we to write
committee reports on the section that
we uh made the motion on or how how is
this going to work calendar quite a few
words on the sections that you wrote up
I'm
uh I'm stitching it I'm stitching the
committee report together so just send
it to me and I'll uh I'll put it in all
right thank
you I'm I'm sorry I've got a question
now what is what is the thing that
starts at 9:30 it's the subcommittee on
Thursday on Senate Bill
uh reprentative goalie if I understand
correctly you're going to put consider a
Report Jeff you're on
mute I need to look at the final product
before I determine whether or not I will
do a
minority Shar enough I will be passing
that Amendment out as soon as it's
it anyone else have anything that needs
done I
am really impressed that we managed to
this you have an impressive group Madam
chair hard working yes
not surprised on the vote on Section
we that case we will close the meeting
fund